strength isn't just about physical
prowess strength is about character and
today's rollback episode highlights a
vegan strong man who at one time was
arguably the or at least among the
strongest men on Earth in both respects
his name is Patrick bogumian originally
released in December of 2015 as an audio
only episode and never before shared on
YouTube Patrick's story and his strength
is absolutely astonishing Patrick is a
guy who fled along with his family the
Iranian Revolution when he was just
seven years old and emigrated to Central
Germany by the age of nine he fell in
love with wrestling on TV he developed
an interest in weight training and as a
young teen he rose quickly through the
ranks to becoming Germany's national
Junior bodybuilding Champion starting in
2011 Patrick was awarded the title of
Germany's strongest man racking up
multiple victories at the European
powerlifting championships and set four
Guinness World Records in various
strength disciplines we're talking about
a guy who can bench 463 pounds squat
794 pounds and deadlift
794 pounds and believe it or not he has
accomplished all of these extraordinary
superhuman Feats on a 100
plant-based vegan diet the house and
wise of which are portrayed in his
appearance in the game changers
documentary and of course explored in
depth today so without further Ado I
sincerely hope you enjoy this epic three
hour adventure with the Armenian Viking
the human Wolverine the original vegan
badass my friend Patrick obumian
last time we saw each other was Toronto
vegfest September of
2012. I think it was 2013 13. that's
right yeah yeah yeah
um
and that was great because that was also
uh the time uh that you broke the world
record by and why don't you explained
exactly what went down yeah
um it was uh actually
um a world record in the Yoke walk and
uh so the what I had to do was I had to
carry 555 kilos for a distance of 10
meters and I had I was allowed to drop
it once and that's what we did there
um and I was quite nervous because I did
it uh a week before that in uh in Berlin
everything went fine but then I had
totally different equipment in Toronto
so I was quite nervous before you know
quite happy after uh after it went well
and I mean you you probably remember how
happy yeah you're well it was it was a
really cool experience because you know
you know I'm an athlete and I've been
around a a lot of different kinds of
athletes but I'd never been even a
spectator to anything you know like what
you were doing so it was very
interesting to be kind of participating
behind the scenes because everything was
being filmed for this documentary and so
I was kind of hanging around it and what
happened was to kind of set the stage is
you were attempting this world record
and and you know for those that are
listening that are in the United States
550 kilograms is about 1200 pounds right
around there right
um
and uh in order to kind of qualify this
everything had to be weighed so there
was all these there was on a stage at
the WestJet stage in in Toronto which is
right on the Harbor on the waterfront
there and uh and there were all kinds of
people weighing all the weights and you
had this sort of scaffold this giant
yoke uh on on which all these plates
were were being added until you know it
weighed exactly 550 kilograms and then
the idea was you were going to walk from
one end of the stage to the other you
had to go 10 meters you're allowed to
set it down once briefly is there a time
limit on how long you can let it rest
for one minute one minute and it was one
minute for the whole thing so if I rest
too long it would have been uh
impossible to do it in one minute so you
got to get you have to get you have to
you have to uh Traverse the 10 meters in
under a minute yeah I got you and who
like who sets those rules like how does
that work well that was um actually
um we talked to to Guinness because it
was a official Guinness World Record and
and we told them how it normally works
at a composition and then they try to
come up with with an idea how to set it
up so it works for them so it was pretty
much them right and they they have to
like send out Representatives like
there's a whole rigmarole process to
that right and then charge you a bunch
of money and yeah it's like the whole
thing I'm I'm quite happy I didn't I was
not the person to pay the money
that's always good so we'll get somebody
else to do that yeah hey I'm the talent
man you know I got enough on my plate
though we had some sponsors and uh the
um you know some of the guys that
organized the whole thing uh so um they
took care of everything so all I had to
do was just carrying the stupid thing
well that's all you should have to do
you know what I mean uh and it was it
was really exciting like a ton of people
showed up there had I don't know a
thousand people there to witness it
happening and and I almost spontaneously
I was like oh I have a GoPro like I
should just film this it wasn't it was
an afterthought I didn't even think like
oh I'm going to make a video out of this
and I just pulled it out of my pocket
and filmed the whole thing and just
didn't even edit it I just put it up on
my YouTube channel basically like that
and that video has probably more views
than anything else I've ever posted on
my YouTube channel which is awesome you
know and I use clips from that now when
I go out and give talks quite frequently
frequently when I'm you know sort of
addressing the the question of of you
know athletic performance and being
plant-based so thank you for that you
gave me that but it was really it was a
privilege and it was a cool thing to see
and it was very exciting I mean you were
definitely you were the thing is though
when you were backstage you were joking
around with people I didn't know you
were nervous you were actually I was I
was like shouldn't he be like away from
people like you seem pretty chill about
the whole thing no I was totally nervous
but uh uh probably I used uh um the
talking and everything just to distract
myself a little bit from my nervousness
so um but but I was really uh nervous
just try to
um yeah try to somehow distract myself
from from the nervousness that I had
right I mean how do you mentally prepare
uh like do you have a routine or like a
processor or a mantra or like how does
that look for you in a perfect situation
I would try to get some uh some some
calm place where I can concentrate and
then I would just uh visualize what I
what I'm going to do so and it's not so
much a formal routine but it's more that
um
I mean most of it happens in the head
right so it doesn't uh depend too much
on the outer circumstances just enough
if I can get some some some quietness
and um just some
some place where some place where I can
just uh I mean be uh be quiet enough to
um to go through everything that that
I'm planning you have to do right yeah
it's it's uh it's interesting to me
because although we're both athletes
we're on different ends of the spectrum
you're you know at the very far extreme
of like strength and power and you know
on the long distance endurance guy and
and you know but I would imagine sort of
the the mental preparation would be
similar but as you're explaining this
I'm thinking you know when I'm when I'm
out there doing my thing it's a it's a
it's sort of a progressive process of
getting more and more fatigued and still
going forward but with you it's a very
precise moment where failure just
happens like you know it's either either
you're going to push through this moment
and get get through the next two seconds
and succeed or it's all gonna end like
everything is very compressed
comparatively yeah yeah absolutely
um so it's um I mean the experience
chance of learning running for a very
long distance I mean not compared to
anything that you do but I still have a
feeling for uh what it's like because uh
I have been dieting for bodybuilding
competitions and in that time
um I had to do cardio work so it's like
a little glimpse of what you do yeah
yeah yeah
um so it's really completely something
else
um
but I mean the the still
though it's uh so different still there
are similarities still you have to um
get managed to uh you have to manage to
in in some way
um tame this Beast inside your head that
says stop I don't want to go on and so
on but it's just in a different way the
Beast is much louder but for for a very
short time
you have to punch it very hard for a
short time and when you're running for a
long distance of course then
um it takes much more time but uh it's a
low grade he's not yeah you're just he's
just he's he's like instead of the Beast
punching you in the face very hard he's
just lightly slapping you constantly
yeah like some kind of water torture
yeah it's different it's interesting
um uh but but the principle is the same
really which is to you know quiet the
chatter of the mind and get as present
as possible like the more anchored in
the moment you are then the more able
you're going to be to be able to like
show up for the task at hand right
and then what separate raised me a
little bit from from most uh people that
I um
that I'm meeting competitions and I that
I compete with is
um that a lot of a lot of the guys will
um try to use aggressiveness to get to
psych up and and get to the point where
they can really unchain uh that inner
energy to um to succeed and for me it
works differently I think actually my my
procedure is probably
um
probably more um
nearer to to what you might do or or
um some endurance guys would do then to
what is typically a typical procedure
for for someone in in my sport because I
really try to
um
um I I don't try to use aggressiveness
and and anger as a source of energy
because I have the feeling that um it I
mean it it unchains energy but at the
same time it uh really makes it hard to
concentrate on on form and so on so for
me it works best to really get calm
um and then the funny thing is as soon
as I um succeed and as soon as I uh
really uh do what what I'm what I'm uh
what I'm planning to do right after the
the last second I'm exploding like I saw
that because I really have to
um it's like really
um having to put all this uh pressure
inside the bottle and then it it pops in
the um like like a like a bottle of
champagne or something right uh right in
the uh last second that I explode yeah
but not in Anger you know there's a
there's a joy and a Jubilation and a
sort of aggressive celebration of it but
it's not coming from a dark place and I
think that's an interesting point that
you made you know that that sort of you
know pound your chest and huff and puff
kind of aggressive you know anger
approach uh you see a lot of that but it
always struck me as sort of uh first of
all it's it takes a lot of energy to do
that so you're wasting a bunch of energy
kind of peacocking around like that and
I I feel like it's unsustainable in the
sense that you have to like if you have
to summon that up every time in order to
perform that's a that's a tall order
right as opposed to like you know when
you're when you're talking I'm like well
it's more of a it's more of a Zen
approach like you know sort of
internally focusing and like just
getting all that energy ready to channel
it in like one very laser you know know
Focus Direction yeah interesting all
right well let's let's track it back you
know like you have such an interesting
story we're here in Frankfurt Germany
and you live you know a couple hours
away North and Berlin uh but your your
Armenian your Iranian you speak amazing
English like what is going on here
you're like this Melting Pot of all
sorts of different cultures yeah packed
into this very compact strong structure
that's that's probably the coolest
description of that person are you the
Armenian uh Viking or are you the human
Wolverine which one is it you know what
I mean you're definitely the human
Wolverine yeah probably the The
Sideburns are growing fast how long have
you been growing those they're insane uh
I think almost half a year now really
it's pretty funny so we'll I'll post a
picture uh on the on the website in the
show notes and I'll also uh embed the
video that we were talking about there
so everybody can check that out but yeah
man where's it all where does it all
begin yeah so it began in Iran at the
Persian Gulf that's where where I'm born
I'm of Armenian origin
um which means that uh some of my
ancestors
um have I don't know I don't even know
if any of my ancestors really came from
Armenia but it's like Armenians are
scattered all around the place in in
Orient so
um and as as much as I can track it back
it seems that my ancestors have been in
Iran for more than 300 years both Mom
and Dad yeah for 300 years so like uh
grand grand anything right right right
so yeah and that's from both sides
um but uh I I could track it back from
from my dad's side for for like almost
300 years
um so still of Armenian origin so that
means that I grew up up speaking
Armenian and Persian two languages and
then when I was seven years old we left
Iran as refugees of War because uh the
year I'm born is 1979 and that's also
the year uh the Iran Iraq war started so
um
yeah when I was seven years old we left
Iran and I grew up from that point I
grew up in Germany so that was the third
thing why Germany I mean what is what
did your what does your dad do or do are
your parents still around no um my my
dad died when I was uh four years old
and I then left the country with my mom
I see
um and um the the plan was actually
that's funny did your dad did your dad
die in the conflict no he he just died
in a car accident I say oh yeah
um and uh the actual plan was to leave
the country and get to the states
actually and we used Germany just as a
Transit country uh where we would stay
as long as the paperworks uh would would
take to get accepted as as uh to get
Asylum for the states and then come as
refugees to the States but my mom would
change the plan and I don't know she
just liked Germany so she decided that
we would stay there together with her
with my uncle her brother so was he
already here or we came together wow and
so you so they didn't know anybody
though yeah right and do you have
brothers and sisters no I was uh I had a
sister but uh she died in a car accident
too so it was just me yeah so so it was
just me my mom and uh and my grandma and
then also my uncle and his family
wow and to the Frankfurt area where
where in Germany at the at the beginning
it was uh so we we arrived here in
Frankfurt
um and then
um the place where I lived uh for the
next years was an hour from here so so
that's uh pretty much where I was based
uh through my childhood and so on yeah
yeah yeah wow and so so uh was is there
like an Armenian community that you guys
became a part of or were you just like
this Outsider kid growing up as a young
person yeah that that was pretty much
the situation so there was it wasn't a
lot of Armenians here and I also um
because it's probably because I uh grew
up with two languages it was quite easy
for me to learn German so um I needed
like six months or so and then I was
fluent but not correct in a correct way
but but still fluent so um it went quite
fast and it was quite easy for me to
um to integrate myself in in into the
community and everything so right is
that how you picked up English so well
too you just have an affinity for
languages you think I think that that's
a part of it and then the other part is
uh that I always had a lot of friends
from the states and then uh
English-speaking uh people
um
um and also when I studied psychology
um all of the literature
um I had to read it's all in English
English right so when you're in college
yeah University right all right so like
what kind of kid were you I mean were
you always a big strong kid were you
playing a lot of sports as a young
person or where does Athletics kind of
enter the picture
um not really it was I think pretty much
the opposite even um and not that I was
uh particularly weak but but I was uh
particularly quite unsporty I wasn't
very athletic uh so and that's pretty
much uh how it is uh how it still is so
if I would have to to run uh I don't
know for a few miles or so it would just
kill me because I just carry too much
weight so
um so in school I was not the athletic
uh type of kid
um what kind of kids did you hang out
with
I think I was one of those uh I was the
leader of The Outsiders I would say I
was the coolest guy within the really
uncool guy right right right I got you
but you seem like a guy who could kind
of navigate in between groups like you
have social skills like you could be
able to like kind of pick which you know
whatever group you know could kind of
like you could be with yeah or no I mean
at least you can say that it was a um
um that I I was with The Outsiders uh on
in purpose so it was not like um
um I hit I didn't have the chance to uh
to get to the mainstream uh guys yeah
but I really uh always like to be a
rebel so that was well I mean you
wouldn't be growing a beard the way that
you grow a beer I don't see you over at
the investment bank with that beard
that's it
cool I got you so uh so where where did
the interest in in I mean the first kind
of thing that you started to explore was
bodybuilding right I mean the sort of
power lifting and strongman stuff came
later that's right
um so it all began when I was 14 years
old and me and a friend of mine who went
to the same school we were both
um very very much into uh professional
wrestling so we watched all the uh who
are your guys yeah who are like your
favorite guys
um I had a few uh guys uh that I really
liked and probably uh The Undertaker
were being what one of my favorites and
then my friend was was a really big fan
of uh the The Hitman Brett The Hitman
hard yeah so um we watched all the all
those stuff um and then we would also
try to do all the things uh by ourselves
right and uh on several occasions we
almost killed ourselves I was breaking
our necks and doing lot of stupid stuff
so at a certain point we just realized
if you really wanted to go for a
wrestling career we would have to build
muscles because as a 14 year old and he
was even one and a half years uh younger
than me so
uh we we really didn't resemble the
stature of uh these guys right so it's
so really the seed here the the the the
spark that Lit all of this was wanting
to be in the WWF absolutely yeah all
right absolutely so that was the first
step and then we began lifting weights
at home and just doing some exercises
some body weight exercises we got some
dumbbells and and did some stuff
um and then we went to the outdoors and
and did some outdoor uh stuff uh also a
lot of running and everything just to
just to get get our overall Fitness and
then at a certain point we uh decided
that we really wanted to go and be
members in the gym so uh that we could
take our training to the next level yeah
right uh and that was a really hard
challenge because most of the gyms
wouldn't uh wouldn't accept this because
we were so young so they were like okay
you have to be at least 16 or you have
to be at least a 18 and so on and
finally we find that we found a gym that
accepted us and we trained there for I
think one and a half years until they
kicked us out because
at that point I think I broke three of
uh of of
um their um
implements that they had why how did you
do that what do you mean like I was too
strong you really so you're just
naturally like all right I'm trying to
get the picture here because I in the
picture I was painting in my mind is
you're you know basically an average
looking kid who's like you know
committed to this dream and is slowly
building up but obviously right out of
the gate you you were I mean you're
built for this just your natural stature
but no you're just naturally strong no
the what you have in your mind is
absolutely correct but uh it didn't take
me a long time because
um we we both my friend and me we were
both so dedicated and so uh motivated
for the whole thing we were pretty much
living for that thing so like when we uh
woke up in the morning we would have our
shake and when when all these other kids
would go to parties we would just do our
routine right and that's why uh after a
year or so we just exploded both of us
we just exploded and that's uh where
where it really came to right when uh
like the hormones kick in of like
puberty and everything like that you're
spending all this time in the gym and
you got posters of all these guys on
your bedroom wall probably at home and
the whole thing I like how you did it
with a friend though right it's like you
guys so like what happened to him yeah
the the funny thing is we're still uh
both in the business but he's uh doing
um so so I'm still an athlete right
um and he's running a website called
body extreme.com
um and he does a lot of uh um
competition cover coverage in
bodybuilding and in strength Sports and
so on so he covers all the pro
bodybuilding events in the states did he
become a bodybuilder himself as well for
for a time yeah so both you guys like
built a life out of this little dream
that you had when you were 14 and joined
your first gym that's pretty cool
absolutely yeah nice so when does the
competition aspect of it come in like
what how so you're getting big right
you're breaking weights you're getting
kicked out of gyms like then what uh
yeah then we found another gym uh that
was a little bit more hardcore uh and
the equipment was uh more stable yeah so
so we moved to that to the other gym and
went on training um and then I had this
time of um probably 10 months or so or
eight months or so where I uh barely uh
trained at all it was a time where I
pretty much did everything that I had
missed in in the years before so I
partied like uh like a jackass I I did
everything that I hadn't done and we
just burned out or like what motivated
that you think no it was just uh
yeah I really didn't didn't think about
it it was just that uh in that moment
that it felt like the thing to do and uh
training was at an in a certain moment
training wasn't that important anymore
so I had this 10 months or so but then
after the 10 months um it it just came
back it
um
um I just felt the urge to uh to to get
back into training and everything and at
that time I lost some weight so before
the 10 months I was already 102 kilos or
so
um so that is what that's what like 210
or something no that's 220 220 okay 220
yeah yeah 220 something
so uh quite heavy for 17 years old yeah
so
um if you were in the United States
you'd be playing football for sure yeah
I think so yeah probably
um so
um then I got back into training and uh
and at that time my friend uh did his
first uh bodybuilding competition uh and
I just prepared him so I was just his uh
without what do you call that it's not
really a coach someone who comes with
you through the competition and just
just helps you with it with everything
right
um so I did that and um
when I watch the competition it somehow
I thought it would be fun to do the same
thing but then at the same moment
bodybuilding was not really what what
what I was I didn't feel uh that I was a
bodybuilder in in the sense because it's
a aesthetic sport it's about looks and I
was all about lifting heavy stuff right
so it felt like where's what happened to
wrestling
um yeah that's that's a good that's a
good question actually so right speaking
of Aesthetics yeah yeah wrestling really
went away
um within the first 12 months when we
realized that lifting weights was such a
such a lot of fun so it really got
replaced by by lifting weights I mean I
still uh
um I still think the the wrestling thing
is really cool but it wasn't the uh it
wasn't the center of our motivation
anymore
so um yeah so he he did his first uh
competition and
then he tried to convince me to do one
and um I it didn't really feel naturally
to me uh so but but I still would let
him convince me
um so I did my first bodybuilding
competition six years after getting back
to training
um and the problem with it was that it
was quite quite uh successful actually
so I won in my county and then at the
German Junior's Championship I would be
placed fourth right and so you're what
like 17 now or something like that 18 at
that point I was 19. so I thought okay
that's weird like you're succeeding but
you're not you're like I don't even know
if this is my thing absolutely right um
and um then I thought okay
um now I have done this and it went much
better than I thought so probably
um I should go for another try because
it was my second last year uh in the
junior division so I thought okay I have
one more shot at the junior Division and
probably if I'm now fourth probably next
year I will be uh it will be possible to
to win so that's what I tried
um so um I came back the year after
uh won the county again and then went
for for the Germans for the German
Nationals
um and my plan was to get into the
middleweight uh category so in a junior
um division they have three categories
three weight categories
um up to seven kilos then up to 80 kilos
that's 77 70 and then up to 80 and then
uh everything above 80 is is the third
and the open category right and my plan
was to get in the middleweight so up to
80 up to 80 kilos and something went
wrong with um with making weight so
um incidentally I got into the
heavyweights uh and uh I thought I'm
completely uh I I don't have any chance
to to do any good at the heavy rates
because I mean most of the guys were
like much taller than me than I was yeah
you didn't cut weight properly like
screwed up somewhere along the line in
terms of like the whole weight cutting
thing actually it was not my fault
actually
um if if we get into the detail it was
um that we wait we measured uh our
weight on a scale
um at the gym for which I was uh I was
competing and their uh scale was uh was
not accurate uh it wasn't calibrated so
I got you yeah so so everyone when we
got to the competition everyone was one
kilo heavier than they thought and and
the problem at that point was that I was
the one who really cut weight absolutely
accurately and perfect so you could be
right at the edge of the the weight
classification absolutely I I didn't
want to leave anything to chance so I
was really at the edge I was absolutely
um
um so I used all I could get to uh
really um make the thing happen because
that was uh the last time that I would
get a shot at the junior so um
and that was the problem so I had one
kilo that I had too much and I had to
get rid of that within two hours or so
um and the problem at that point was for
a bodybuilding competition you um caught
a lot of Weights by uh by trying to get
rid of your body fat
um obviously and then also you
exaggeration you dehydrate your body so
I was already completely dehydrated
there wasn't anything there's no more
water to go no yeah amputation would be
the only thing so so I lost 600 grams or
so within those two hours by running
spitting and uh I mean I couldn't even
go to the bathroom or anything because
there wasn't any water in me to to get
rid of I even tried to uh throw up
didn't work there was anything in my
stomach bizarre thing all right so what
happens in the competition yeah so um so
I had to go to the opens and then uh
um I was expecting to be any anywhere
between fifth place or or anything like
that because there was such a lot of
huge guys there and what that actually
happened was I won the overall thing so
I won the category and then one uh the
overall title too
um and that was the reason motivated me
a lot and that was the reason that I
came back in the year after that
um at the
um what is it called in English at the
men's category like
um I don't know what that means no no
it's uh after Juniors you're just
seniors yeah like just regular like Yeah
The Real Men characters
that's cool that's a real mad Catherine
yeah so I would come back uh um as a
quite uh young guy and and I think I
placed ninth also and that was the last
time that I competed at uh building for
for 10 years after in 2009 I did it one
once more but for 10 years that was it
and um in the years after that I just
I think four or five years I just
trained for fun until 2006 and 2006 was
then uh when I did my first uh strongman
competition all right we're gonna get
into that and unpack all of that but you
know I just while we're on the whole
body building thing I mean it's such a
it's such a weird and very specific like
subculture right like like it's a sport
but it's also like this weird beauty
contest of you know Aesthetics and and
posing and posturing it like it's
there's nothing else like it really in
sport like it's its own strange Universe
with its own rule book I suppose
absolutely and the the thing is that the
actual sport and and the actual work
that you do happens in the gym so
normally you when you have a competition
the the actual performance that you do
happens on happens at the competition
but as a bodybuilder you really have to
perform in the in the preparation
before the competition and at the
competition You're just showing the
result of yeah what you have done for
months and years there was a period of
time where uh I was living in the in the
Venice area of Los Angeles and I
belonged to the Gold's Gym in Venice
like the home of bodybuilding that's
where you know you know it's where
Arnold Schwarzenegger you know got his
start Etc and and during this period of
time you would go and you'd see like a
lot of the professional bodybuilders I
mean and even like the former ones like
you know Lou Ferrigno was there like
every day and and these female
bodybuilders and they just clock in at
eight or nine in the morning and they're
there until five or six at night like
every single day you know this is like
their job you know they go and I was
like okay I get it
um but just observing it like was just
it I'm like I'm trying to relate to like
what's going on and I'm like it's so
weird but they and I and I feel like
um
it can be and I'm not saying this is for
everyone of course but it can be this
kind of uh receivership or or kind of a
safe haven for people that have like
body dysmorphia issues or or you know
weird kind of like psychological issues
about their their how they look Etc
because it's so kind of self-oriented in
that regard and and also I think that
there's a sense of you know once they
become so gigantic they almost become
they they're they're marginalizing
themselves in public you know because
they look so different than everyone
else so this is the place where they can
come and be with their like-minded
community and feel supported yeah and
and I would observe you could see that
social Dynamic like you know in action
it's very interesting yeah
uh everything you said was right yes
okay and I can agree and what about I
mean what about like uh steroid use I
mean you know what is I mean did you how
does that work in the world that you
inhabited at that time
yeah that's uh that's a real uh big
issue I had some funny uh some some uh
funny experiences with that because uh
as I told you we uh we're thrown out the
first gym where we were
um and um
um and the reason was uh pretty much
that we were really uh getting getting
stronger and uh much uh much faster than
anyone would expect that so some of the
gym members would would really get angry
and most cases it was
um you have those guys that that are um
in the gym and you see uh what you
described uh that they get in the gym
quite early in the morning and then you
see them until the evening and you have
those guys that really do that but you
don't see them train actually yeah
they're most kind of walking around
talking to each other and like sort of
flexing in the mirror and observing
themselves yeah and then most of the
time you'll see them even at the um
um what is it called um in the bar
having having a shake or anything or
even
smoking cigarettes or or anything else
so and what they do has pretty much
nothing to do with with sport or uh with
a healthy lifestyle or anything
um and those guys would get really angry
on us because we were really doing well
like uh after after one and a half years
I think I was one of the strongest guys
in the whole gym
uh and I was 16 years old and
um so some of them would like scream uh
to our face that we're using steroids
and I I don't think and the funny part
of it was at that point I wouldn't even
know what they're talking about and I
was like I told uh told my friend what
the hell are they talking about what is
that even
um so up to the point uh until we left
the gym I I didn't even know what it was
and then of course in the in the years
later
um I learned a lot a lot about it
because I met a lot of people who tried
I mean some of them try try to sell you
something some of them if you're in that
world it's going to be in your face
right absolutely absolutely uh and it's
um one one big issue is uh that I have
the feeling of is
um when when I see what uh what the
government is doing to to get uh the uh
the problem handled is that they can't
really concentrate on uh on professional
athletes and trying to find ways to make
them uh work in a uh
in a natural way and and don't use any
performance enhancing drugs and so on
and I always have this feeling that they
really over oversee the problem that
that is really much worse and it's not
the professional athletes because in
most cases if they do use anything they
use it they get their stuff by by a
doctor or by anyone and they know what
they do
but it's really in in all those gyms all
these kits that really get uh influenced
and and get get in touch with uh with
people who try to tell uh sell them all
kinds of uh shits so uh that was really
a big challenge to not get into this um
uh really self-destructive uh um culture
where um I mean you can really compare
it with uh other types of of drug use
because
um in most cases if you if you're using
drugs um the problem is that you're like
in a vicious circle where you
um destroy um
first your health and then also your um
your
psychological uh um
yeah your second your psychological
health so you're really destroying your
your persona uh and it gets worse and
worse
um uh and if you're lucky you get out of
the circle
um and if if not you really go down to
hell
um and it's just it's the same thing if
you uh take a look on on hard rocks or
on alcohol or on steroids it's also
always the same thing and I'm really
happy that we were able to stay away
from that and uh yeah get get through
the whole process uh without being being
pulled down in this in this thing I mean
do you think that that perhaps that
might have been you know a factor in in
you kind of stepping outside of that
that that sport I mean you know do you
think that you can be competitive
internationally without using that kind
of performance enhancing drug I mean the
guys at the top of the game they're just
so freakishly big like you just look at
them you're like that's not humanly
possible without assistance
logical assistance but I really don't
don't think that way because
um one thing that you forget
when you think like that is
um you forget the role of genetics if
you look at a
basketball player for instance
um who is like eight feet tall or seven
feet tall
um
there is nothing to uh to to get that
big uh um that no drug or anything that
you can use to get that big and you
would never think in in the terms of how
can you be be that tall because you know
okay he has the genetics to to grow
that's all in it's the same thing with
being muscular or being strong
um some people just have completely
different genetics so
um I think it's it's a little bit
misleading if you if you um think in
terms of if someone is um
uh is doing well at a certain sport it
must be because of the perform
performance enhancing drugs because what
I learned uh from uh from everything
that I experienced in that world is
the the part the performance enhancing
drugs play is probably
let's say I mean
it's not more than 20 percent of the
whole performance
so you you would never get someone who
is not already on a very high level to
win a competition with drugs right but
at the very highest level 20 is a lot
when you're differentiating at the one
percent level you know the best and the
second best absolutely it can it can be
uh what what depends or it can be what
is going to decide if if you're going to
be 10th place or if you're going to be
uh the first place right but it's never
possible if you don't do anything else
in in the correct way and uh don't don't
have all the other ingredients is
it will give you nothing right but it
but but at the highest level of
bodybuilding I mean it's not it's it's
not a clean sport I mean even by these
guys own admission you know this is like
yeah they're all doing that right I mean
I mean if you take a look on the
professional bodybuilders
um yeah it's pretty much no no one uh I
think there's no Pro bodybuilder who
would really uh
um say they do it naturally no and also
you have the natural competitions for
that reason because it's agreed upon
everybody knows the the ones that are
not in the not natural competition are
you know using something most likely but
but the really bad thing about that is
uh I know some natural bodybuilders
a lot of them use stuff too so and but
still you you see a difference between
between the natural bodybuilders and uh
what what can I call them unnatural or
Supernatural but it's supernatural is a
good one semi-natural and he admittedly
completely unnatural
so you already see this big difference
um and and still there are some guys who
who would find a way to trick the tests
or anything yeah so you you will always
have that problem
um because as as soon as you have a new
test for human beings so yeah that's
that's right they find a way to uh to to
trick it so
um
yes so so bodybuilding might be a little
bit special on that because it's such a
I always call it a Cosmetics board
because I think it's it's a lot about
uh the the look and uh a look that you
can only maintain for like an hour yeah
that's that's the funny uh part of it
especially for me it was exactly uh how
it worked so I would diet for half a
year or so almost kill myself because
because naturally I'm I'm always
overweight I'm not in a very good shape
so that that's how I look naturally so
if I really want to get in that shape
that you need on the on the stage I
would really have to almost kill myself
I would do for instance like paper thin
skin where all the veins are popping
through and all that kind of stuff yeah
I wouldn't even get to that point but I
tried to get as close as I could so so
what I would have to do is for instance
six uh six hours of cardio a day so
three hours after uh training for
Ultraman yeah that's why I said I can't
I can uh um I have some experience where
I can like relate to to know what you do
but then of course these six hours were
on a very low uh um
uh um performance yeah intensity level
while you are going for probably six
hours no a lot of the endurance training
is that it's at a very you know it's out
of it's at a pretty low you know you're
in that your aerobic kind of fat burning
Zone yeah
yeah so um so I would really have to do
a lot of uh uh a lot of cardio training
and also a lot of dieting like uh being
on almost zero carbs for several weeks
uh to to get to the point and then right
after the competition I would start just
stuffing everything I I could find into
my face so he's like literally changing
in front of your very eyes yeah so I
would like gain 10 kilos in a day or so
well yeah I mean clearly there is a
genetic element to it because some
people are just naturally ectomorphic
and you know you can see the the veins
under their skin you know normally or
whatever and you're a super strong guy
but you know you're not genetically sort
of you know kind of cut out for that no
I'm not built for bodybuilding actually
if you really look on uh
my physique it's it's pretty much built
for power lifting yeah that's that's
actually just the sport that I'm
building you're perfectly built for that
so let's talk about that right so so uh
so you have this you know sort of
bodybuilding career and uh and you
decide to change directions yeah
um yes so what what uh first happened is
that I went away from competing for
quite a long time
um and I just trained for fun so being a
normal dude yeah yeah so in in that time
uh I also
um went to evening school to uh to get
uh uh what is it called uh true uh
master's degree like uh yeah what you
need to get to the university oh oh I
got you in order to go to university
yeah so I did that in that time um and
then in 2006 uh I went uh I started uh
my my uh psychology study
and
um also I in 2005 so one year before
that uh I became vegetarian
um and then in 2006 uh in in the first
year of studying psychology I also
started with uh strongman competitions
uh and the reason for that was and this
is this is quite related to uh the
self-destructing thing that that we just
spoke about
um so the reason
um that I started with strongman was the
following um I was already studying
psychology and uh it wasn't
some winter evening and I was just
surfing through some sites and then it
came to my I was actually just checking
some stuff on on Wikipedia and then it
came to my mind to check out Wikipedia
for uh some some of those wrestling guys
and I started checking some of those
guys and I was like what happened to
those guys you know what they were doing
now yeah and a lot of them were just
dead
like the British Bulldog Owen Hart
um a lot of those guys really weren't
alive anymore and I was shocked because
it was like literally one decade after I
watched all those guys as a kid and I
was a fan of all the the whole thing and
now they were like 50 of those guys were
dead yeah Rowdy Roddy Piper just died
too right how old was yeah the The
Ultimate Warrior just died a lot a lot
of a lot of the guys aren't alive
anymore
so
um so I checked it and and obviously uh
being in the whole Sport and knowing
what what happens there uh I knew what
what would be the cause of such a lot of
people uh dying in such a lot of um
young uh young age and with the
wrestlers it's not not even only the uh
the performance enhancing drugs but the
problem is also that sometimes they just
have to use stimulating drugs to to just
because they're always on uh on on the
road and always touring around uh so and
they always have to perform so it's also
a lot about
um some drugs to just stay be able to to
perform and then also
pain is a factor I think so they also
use a lot of painkillers and and stuff
like that so it's really unhealthy
lifestyle day right right right a lot of
a lot of them have so I checked those
and because I was uh I was trying to
orient myself and trying to find a new
um challenge
a new thing to go for and I thought okay
wrestling is not cool I don't want to
die so so uh so I just plus it wasn't
really like cool period anymore anyway
like that period had kind of come and
gone right like wrestling had its moment
but that was kind of in the 80s that
that's right but but for me it wasn't
for me
because I mean the funny thing was I
wasn't even following it that that was
the reason why I was so shocked that a
lot of them died because I wasn't
following it for such a long time but
remembering uh
um the the old times I was just as
enthusiastic so I thought okay probably
it would be cool to get back to that
yeah you're stuck in 1989.
in a certain way
so um yeah so after uh after realizing
that uh it was so bad with with all
those guys uh I thought okay wrestling
isn't the thing so let's go for strong
man uh because I was also when I was a
kid I was also a big fan of strong man
uh and and I would never have when I
when I started lifting weights I would
never have the feeling that I could end
up myself as a strong man
because normally those guys are huge
they're Giants they're like
and they're physically tall so how tall
are you I'm I'm I think
uh in in feet I don't know actually it's
like about five four five five something
like that maybe yeah something around
that yeah it's one 170 uh centimeters
all right so um well like but let's
let's hold on one second here so let's
put a pin in strong man and I want to
Define that and really flush that out
but you breezed by one very kind of
salient point which is you made this
decision to go vegetarian and you kind
of brushed it off and went on to the
next thing so so you know what what was
the motivation behind that
um it was uh in the in the last weeks uh
before I uh got uh got into University
um and the whole thing started uh with
with the thinking process with the
internal uh thinking process where
um
um I just realized that throughout my
life I had been quite compassionate with
animals uh and in a way that I perceived
animals as pretty much the same
made of the same stuff that we are made
of so when I saw animals suffering it
was for me the same thing as seeing a
children suffering or or another human
being suffering just built into your DNA
it is naturally your whole life you've
been that like have extra Sensitivity I
mean when I was really a small child I
hadn't uh
I would kill some ants and stuff like
that so so it it came off right right
but I mean just just by anecdotal you
know in a little anecdotal story we just
we just took the train today from the
Frankfurt book fair about you know
almost maybe a little over an hour to
where we're staying and we got off the
train platform and it was Julia and
myself and one other and and you were
with us and suddenly we turned around
and said where's Patrick we couldn't
find you and then you you showed up and
you said oh I saw you know I saw a bird
on the platform I wanted to make sure I
wanted to see if he was dead or or
whether he was suffering still yeah yeah
yeah that's like that's not something
that like the average person would do
like I didn't even notice the bird yeah
I think that's something probably where
I'm a little bit special like uh for uh
I mean if if I see uh a little worm or
something on the floor uh in in the
train like uh once I I saw a really very
very very small uh caterpillar
uh you couldn't even it was so small you
couldn't almost even see it it was
really like uh probably
like an ant or so right and a little uh
green thing uh and it was on the floor
and what it was obvious if I don't put
it up it would just be killed by someone
yeah and it was a full bus so what I did
was I got on the floor and everyone was
looking at me what is that idiot doing
there so I tried to get it in in a way
on my hand without killing it and that's
that's really touching it you can smush
it right yeah absolutely so so it was
already a big
it was already a heavy task to to get it
from the floor without killing it I use
a piece of paper then I got out of the
bus uh in the middle of nowhere where I
really didn't want to go to
um uh got uh to to
um to a place where there was a little
bit grass and so on and I tried to save
it so um
but that's how I see the world so um for
me I just think that small little thing
wants to live too so
um it's like or sometimes I just think
um
um if you perceive us humans from from a
much higher perspective we're like
little ants too on this big planet so um
if I don't have any pity with this small
little thing why should some higher
being like I mean some people believe in
that I'm a um atheist so um I don't
believe in any deity or anything but
some some people believe and then I
think okay why are they
um
um expecting some higher being to have
pity with us if you don't have pity with
this little worm right and pity might
not even be the right word it's more
like compassion right because pity kind
of implies you feel sorry for them yeah
um yeah that's interesting and that I
mean where do you
like where does that come from you know
I mean you know one thing I didn't know
about you was your father and your and
your sister passing away in a and and
was it in the same car accident or those
it was okay do you remember that I mean
I can't help but think perhaps you know
the pain of that experience might have
informed this you know sort of
compassion or perspective
um
I don't really know
um I think uh
in a way I'm just a little bit different
uh and I think it uh there's a lot of
ingredients too that that caused this
being different and uh but as a psych
somebody who studied psychology yeah
right if you had to diagnose yourself
um yeah that that's why I said it it's a
lot of ingredients is and one of those
uh might be that I lost my dad so um so
early
um and also what's happened is um
uh I was a single child after that so
um and also my mom had had to work so I
would be alone for for quite quite uh
long uh long time every day
um my grandma being being the one who
was with me at home so um
um
so when I was like uh nine years old or
10 years old I would think about stuff
that normally uh um children my age
wouldn't think of like uh I would I
would uh think a lot about the universe
and why we are here and if there is
something like
um this this concept of uh evil good and
evil I would think a lot about that so
when I was nine years old or so I would
ask my mom uh my mom
um if what decides
who who we are If That's genetics and
experience
how can someone be evil because none of
those you don't choose your genetics you
don't choose the experiences that you do
so how can someone be evil
stuff like that so so I will see a
little bit don't ask me questions yeah
yeah that's that's how it was I like
asking these like super intense you know
questions of the universe yeah so so I
was a little bit strange as a child
already
um and um I mean one reason was that I
was alone because I lost my dad and I
lost uh my my sister uh so early and
also I had to cope with the situation of
losing them and not really and I was
four years old so I wasn't really able
to
um understand what really happened so
it's pretty
um
pretty much a kickstarted this whole uh
thinking a lot thing that I had in me
and then another ingredients would be um
that I grew up in this country where War
was happening and I was only so the only
people around me were my mom and my
grandma so there was no other man that I
could relate to when when things were
getting out of hand for example
um when when we we would be bombarded
and then everyone was afraid and then
screaming and everything
um and I had all these situations where
I
had to find a way to uh
um to handle and cope with with my
little uh psyche that well there's a
lack of control right there's all these
all this chaos happening around you and
and tragedy and you have no ability to
you know sort of control that situation
and so it's it's interesting then
comparing that to to you know strength
training in the gym or bodybuilding
that's something that you can control
completely you know you put this weight
on you lift it this is the result that
you get you eat this much food like it's
it's very much almost like uh it could
be an obsessive compulsive exercise in
trying to control your small little
Universe yeah and that's exactly where
it came from the the origin was this
lack of control in my childhood and then
the feeling uh that you get when as soon
as you realize that you can control your
body and you can control it fully uh by
deciding what you want to do with it and
then just make it work as as you want it
so that was the origin of that
and also
um having all these situations where I
saw other people in distress and and uh
in panic uh when when something happened
um I also had this urge of being able to
to help in a way I really wanted to help
and then at the same point I was just
just a little child so I couldn't do
anything so I would have these Daydreams
of The Rescuer yeah of uh I would like
dream of situations where something bad
happens and then I I'm able to help it
everywhere yeah
um interesting so that's probably
something that relates to this this
compassion thing uh for animals and so
on but but I think at the end of the day
um I think this uh perceiving
um other other living beings as uh equal
to us that's really something that comes
down naturally I don't think that
there's any experiences or or anything
in my childhood that really relates to
that uh special thing right I think
that's just uh because I mean I never
found a reason to not think that they're
the same so I think that's that's that's
probably the most important part were
you as a younger person before you
decided to go vegetarian that must have
caused you some consternation to be
eating these the you know the meat and
you must have just you rationalized that
by saying well I have to because that's
what I need to do to be alive and
healthy no that's the shocking part of
it the shocking part of it was that up
to 2005 I didn't even realize that there
was something going wrong and the
problem is when you're eating something
you don't see the animal
I mean uh and and that was exactly what
happened before I decided to go
vegetarian so uh what I realized is
that there was this complete
um
um
a contradiction uh in in my behavior and
in the way that I perceive the world so
when I would see an animal suffering I
would instantly have the urge to help
um and it would uh
so I would like
um have some some birds with broken legs
or anything he was always bringing
animals home to the house as a kid
at that time I uh I had um I wasn't at
home anymore so I was living with my
ex-girlfriend at their uh at their house
and
um so we would both bring a lot of
animals home and we would then take care
of them and then uh set them free uh
when when after helping them
um and what I just realized was it
doesn't make any sense to put time and
energy in helping one animal and then at
the same time eating another animal
right and that's so straightforward and
it was so shocking that it took me like
26 years to get to the point to to see
the contradiction
um but once I started thinking about it
there was actually no other way than to
say okay I have to stop this
um so that was the point in in the the
most important question for me was
would I eat it if I would have to kill
it and the answer was no and then I
thought it's what I do is just dishonest
because right because ethically you're
just abdicating that decision to
somebody else as a rationalization and
saying well I'm not killing it but but
by proxy you really are yeah and uh the
the bad part of it is that you're doing
the whole thing unconsciously on
unconsciously consciously so you you
most of the people I think I would say
90 of people
um would actually have the same problem
I had at that point But as soon as you
go to the uh to the grocery store and
you you get all those animal products
you don't see the actual being behind
the product of course you just see this
packaged
piece of whatever it's specifically
designed to prevent you from from seeing
that or being in any way connected to
the process of what delivered that meat
to the grocery store in that nicely you
know cellophane wrapped package because
most people you're you're you're
extraordinarily sensitive but most
people everybody I think is inherently
compassionate and has sensitivity right
so anybody who would actually kind of
walk you know with the animal through
that whole process from beginning to end
would be horrified and that's why there
are AG guide laws and all these sort of
sort of structures built up to prevent
the consumer from seeing or in any way
being connected to that process because
the more connected we are the more we
will realize like you know what are we
doing this is insanity yeah absolutely
and um the thing is
um this whole culture of eating animals
comes from
from from a a point in time where it was
part of surviving
and the the thing is we don't need it
anymore to survive and that's that's
really uh the the problem that occurs as
soon as you start thinking about it
there's a cultural attachment to this
misconception that we are obligate
omnivores that that at a very
fundamental level that we need animal
products in order to to thrive right and
and your experience and my experience
has been quite the opposite actually and
when you have that moment and you
realize like wait a minute like not only
do I not need it like I'm actually
feeling better and Performing better
without it it's like taking the blue
pill in The Matrix and suddenly this
whole sort of world opens up to you
where you start to really see things
with a little bit more objectivity and
Clarity and you begin to question like
well what's really going on here
absolutely and uh what what you
um what you then see is that we're doing
a lot of things in in everyday life
without thinking about it without Quest
sending it yeah yeah it's not just this
issue yeah yeah it's it's a lot of
things and a lot of things where you
really uh before you get out of matter
out of the metrics you think it's just
natural and it's just what I do because
I want to do it and then you find out no
it's I'm just prag programmed to do all
these things by culture and as soon as
you step step one one step back and then
have a look on on the whole thing from a
little bit uh higher perspective you you
just see all right so what would another
example an example of that be for you
a lot of things that that people do do
to each other like for instance how you
manage the relationship
like this um
um
for instance we are used to
um
have
um uh relationship to uh to another
human being
same or or
a different sex and we we have this
feeling of that that can always be a
relationship of two people
it's actually completely cultural it
could be 20 people loving each other or
or anything
um and um
it's a it's a lot of things that that
would you um like in the the funny part
of it is that it's really fundamental
things it's not just things that uh like
I don't know like smoking or or anything
that that is not really watching too
much TV or something yeah it's not
things like that but uh when it comes to
the relationship to other human beings
and when it comes to eating that's
things that have to do with uh with
surviving and that that are really the
most fundamental things in in life and
we still have no clue why we do it the
way we do it that's so true
and and it's really a big eye-opener as
when you get to the point where you
really see that you're doing all this
stuff just by just because you're
programmed too right uh and it's so
great because
um then all these new ways open up like
you you find yourself in in a big room
where um and before that you you had to
just roll on this one rail and it was
only one direction and then you find all
these new directions or all these new
possibilities right Gestalt is a German
word right the Gestalt of just the sort
of you know cultural imperative of you
know as a this is what you do and then
when you're this age you do this and
then you go to high school and then you
go to college and then you work and you
rent an apartment and you lease a car
you know wait a minute what is going on
you know what I mean what's really
insane here that's that's that's so
interesting and funny so all right so do
you have this Epiphany in like one
lightning bolt or is this a gradual
progression of realizing you know what
like I just like there's too much
dissonance with you know between my
value system and and how I'm behaving I
need to align these a little bit better
though it was really uh
a clear cut at that moment but it had no
external Factor like like some people
watch watch a film like I know a lot of
people who watch earthlings for for
example and then they go vegan or
anything
um but uh for me there was no external
Factor it was really just this one
moment where where I just became aware
of uh of the problem
um and that was it just but yeah yeah
that was it so so I made the decision
um it didn't really uh work out well uh
on on the first run so what happens was
after two days of no meat
um we we would go out and then after
going out
um and after not eating for quite a long
time we would get to a place with our
friends uh where they had pretty much
nothing that was with without meat right
on the sausages
stuff like that and then or Germany and
then they had salami pizza so
um
and then I thought okay what am I going
to do now I'm dying I'm starving here
yeah so uh at the end uh I I ordered a
salami Pizza
and then I took the salami off the pizza
and I
ate the pizza and then I was what am I
doing here
it's it's it's already happened so so I
thought okay this is helping no one
so uh the the first try ended after
those two days with eating the salami
pizza and then the day after I would get
back to it and then it went on for six
years yeah
and so and and this is the same time
where you're looking for a physical
challenge also and you start to get
interested in the strongman stuff this
is probably six months uh or or a few
months before that before I uh was
looking for for the physical challenge
so like several months before uh
starting to think about strongman I uh I
made this decision and and I went
vegetarian right and did you think at
that time I mean were you perceiving
yourself as an athlete did you did you
contemplate the impact that that might
have on your ability to perform in the
gym no and that was uh the um
that was actually
the the lucky chance that I had because
um I was totally
um
expecting my performance levels to go
down because I
to the 12 years before that I had always
trained with with and I with a lot of
animal products especially a lot of meat
so I thought okay this is going to uh
drinking like raw eggs like Rocky and
doing all that kind of stuff not so much
I was more into dairy products I would
like drink 10 liters of milk and and
stuff like that
um so so I thought okay um this is going
to uh be a problem for my performance
but I don't care so much because at that
point I was just training for fun so I
thought okay it's it's no problem it's
okay like that's a bargain I'm
comfortable with yeah and what that
happened was the exact opposite like in
the six months after that
um I was doing so well I gained five
kilos of muscle mass or of body weight
um I was getting stronger than I was
before that's the interesting thing
because in the gym you can you can
calibrate it exactly you know exactly
what your numbers are right so those
numbers went up I mean did you very the
kind of training that you were doing so
it was the only variable the change in
the diet yeah that's that's uh the cool
thing because did you lose weight and
then put it back on like we were talking
on the train like a David Carter on the
podcast the 300 pound vegan football NFL
football player and he lost a bunch of
weight and then had to put it on but
then ultimately he ended up much
stronger in the gym and faster more
agile like across the board like all his
numbers were better but but he had like
a little dip first and then had to kind
of you know sort of build the foundation
again yeah no I I hadn't uh
and anything like that because um four
years before uh that point I was just
training for fun so it was uh pretty
much uh the all those four years where
where uh plateau and the only thing that
changed was the diet the only thing that
changed was that I got rid of the uh the
meat and what really happened is I mean
you you won't gain any weight just by
giving up meat what really happened is
um because I was not eating meat my
upper my appetite was much more because
I had this feeling of I had to get what
I was eating it wouldn't fill me up so I
was like actually I have to eat more and
that's something that's really crucial
because meat is really giving your your
stomach a lot of work and when you get
rid of that
you're just more hungry so you you will
eat a lot of more stuff and then I just
made sure that that I ate good stuff and
so I gained weight and and the
performance levels went up so
um the the reason for for the
performance uh um gains was not so much
um the
giving up meat by itself but it was
because giving up meat I had much more
appetite and I had much more room so to
say for for all the good stuff that I
then consumed interesting so so was
there a moment in the gym where you were
like wait a minute what's going on like
I just pushed you know you know X number
of kilograms or pounds like that's never
happened before like what what it would
you know did how did that look for you
was there a specific day in the gym
where it hit you like wow this is
actually making me better though it was
more gradual because it was uh coming
gradually over this six month period uh
it was not so much uh this
um this experience of of uh having that
one point where we realize what is going
on but it was much much more I'm just
looking back those six months that I saw
okay something went really really good
in the the last six months and then I
obviously realized okay that's since I
uh uh stopped eating meat right and and
so was the kind of gains that you were
experiencing was that related to this
renewed desire to find a challenge like
did that give you like a spark of like
enthusiasm you know after sort of being
on a plateau for a while no um because
um
I I gave up meat in 2005 and then six
months later was was the point where I
started thinking about uh looking for
for a new challenge and I think it was
pretty much vice versa it was I realized
that I was doing so well so I thought I
have to use this or something yeah
because I was feeling like okay this is
uh probably this will go on
um and uh this will open up some
perspectives on on being competitive at
something so I was looking for new
challenges and I wasn't uh motivated to
do any bodybuilding anymore so I was
just checking if I what I could use this
for
um and that's where we get to the point
where I was looking for the wrestlers
and then right came up with strong men
all right so explain what the world of
strongman competitions is yeah
so strongman is a very young sport
and it's been established in 1977.
and it's it all started with this TV
show called The World's Strongest Man
yeah yeah I was just gonna say like it's
it's like it Harkens back to like the
70s I remember as a kid watching these
shows even like Battle of the Network
stars they would have them do these
crazy you know like you know chopping
trees down and and carrying logs and
things like that yeah pulling cars yes
and the reason that they had all these
uh new uh events uh was was quite uh
quite straightforward because
um they wanted to find out who is really
the strongest man in the world and for
finding that out they had to take
um athletes from different sports uh who
consider themselves to be strong put
them together and then have
um some kind of competition where they
can they could compete against each
other and to not make it unfair and and
not giving any of these athletes um an
advantage over the others they invented
new right types of strength tests and
and that's pretty much the reason why
you have all these crazy things because
um so you you would have weight lifters
power lifters
bodybuilders wrestlers
all kinds of uh um strong guys
um and so so no one would have an
advantage they would have events like
right lifting and not lifting um yeah
lifting cars or um or pulling trucks
or characters it's like it's like
gymnastics right you have a series of
different uh events and then you it's
like a point system right and you have
the overall like sort of winner who can
kind of or like the decathlon right
where there's all these different
contests and the overall winner is the
person who kind of scores the best
across them all exactly that's that's
the way it's measured so it's uh while
in other sports we're like running or or
anything you have this one discipline
and then you can just measure uh the the
speed or or whatever or how how long
long they jump or anything uh or the
distance and then you have a winner uh
with strong man it is always different
events and they are very different from
each other so one is for Speed and I
mean they're all for strength but in in
one you might want to be very uh um
quick also and then the other event is
probably just throwing something so just
to make to make all these all these
things uh comparable and and to have a
system where it all fits together uh you
just um get get get points by the way
that you place in in in the event so
um that's the reason why
um the the sport is so the perfect way
to uh to compete uh to be compatible uh
competitive uh at strongman is if you
are
um
quite good
in all events you don't have to be crazy
strong on one event because it doesn't
give you any extra points if you like uh
throw the thing away uh
um double the distance like everyone
else does you just have to win it or you
just have to be right so you just want
to basically what you want to do because
you're you're doing so many events is is
be the best but conserve conserve as
much energy as possible for the next
event so you want to just win by the
narrowest of margins just like the way
that you were trying to cut weight yeah
perfectly yeah and sometimes you don't
even have to win sometimes you can win a
competition without winning any of the
events but but just by being in the top
three rights yeah I mean that's the way
like the Tour de France works like a
stage race and cycling like the the GC
the overall winner you know he may not
win a single stage of the whole thing
but it's sort of placing the highest day
in and day out and is there are there
like style points too like how good you
look lifting the car
there should be a beard category because
you would definitely win that one that
would be a good good one no um there
isn't anything like that but it would
totally make sense because because
probably a lot of those guys have beards
too right that would be stiff
competition
but I think you would take it yeah
probably I would have uh the most
special beer yeah so so the thing is um
um now you have this competition which
actually started as a TV show so you
have this unique mixture of
of a sport of a real sport where you
really uh have to perform
um and and and a show that is really uh
meant to entertain people and you have
all this brings it back to wrestling
yeah so it's not like that right you
have to be a showman yeah that there is
some some part of it is still so there's
a style aspect to it
um maybe not scored in points but
certainly present in the sort of ethos
of it yeah absolutely I mean um at the
end of the day you also the one thing is
you want to win a competition but then
the other thing is you also want to be
popular you want to be loved by the
people so uh of course if you put a put
out a Big Show and and you entertain
people they're going to like that so
um you have a lot of uh um personalities
there
um who do that in a great way and and
who are very charismatic
um and that's part of the game but you
don't get any points for that right
right
um yeah so so the whole thing began in
uh 1977 and then it went on for for
several years and with the years um the
whole thing grew so it was then not only
um the the world's strongest men uh
annually but it was also uh qualifying
uh series to to get to to get there and
then uh it started to uh to have babies
all around the world and and uh the so
all countries will would have their
national championships and so on to get
uh qualified to get to the series and so
on so it grew a lot uh until 2016 on
2006 uh where I started to
um to scan the internet for uh like this
looks good I could do this this could be
my thing the the main aspect was that I
found out that they had begun one year
before they had begun uh to establish a
lightweight category and this
lightweight category was up to 105 kilos
and that was my body weight and I
thought Okay the reason why I have
haven't tried that is because I didn't
want to compete against guys who are
like double my weight I have like 300
pounds so so I thought okay um I
wouldn't have any chance to to be those
guys but if I have a category who is
um my body weight and and um so none of
the other athletes is going to be bigger
than me probably I would have have a
chance to be competitive and and I'm
always quite uh
so if I do something I really want to be
good at it if if I don't see a chance to
be good at it I won't do it so so I
thought okay this might be a chance for
me to make use of my gains in the in the
last six months
yeah so um I would
um contact uh um
the president of the of the German
Federation uh German uh strongman
Federation and as it is not such a big
sport you actually have the chance to to
get through to those people
whoa somebody called yeah so so I uh
just uh asked him
um I just sent him a message and and
told him my numbers and everything and
just asked him if you would think that
it's realistic to um to try to come to
one of the uh newcomer competitions uh
and uh then I also met him in the gym
and we we talked together and he was he
thought he even said he thinks that I
could be very competitive actually in
the lightweight categories because uh
there wasn't such such a lot of athletes
uh who would
be much stronger than me so so I thought
okay I give it a try and in 2006 I had
my first uh competition I did several
newcomer competitions and I also tried
uh to get to the Nationals in in the
lightweight category and so hold on a
second so so tell me about the first
newcomer company the first competition
did you just did you just go in there
and nail it like what happened no
um I don't know if I even did I even win
my uh body weight category I mean one
thing that that I found out was there
were certain events where I could really
destroy anyone and that's pretty much
something that stayed uh until today so
there are certain events where I'm
really really good and I can compete
with anyone in the world and that's
mostly
um events that that we call uh overhead
events where you have to lift something
over your head like shocking let's call
it overhead event
is like a keg lift or not the log lift
right and some of the other ones though
I would imagine involve like certain new
skills that like would take some time to
learn yeah absolutely and and some of
them uh just uh you just need a certain
type of uh uh of anatomy uh that I
didn't have like uh when you have the
so-called Atlas Stones uh that's round
uh concrete balls that you have to grab
and and put on a platform and if you
don't have long arms right
I mean it happens but it's really much
much more uh work uh than for someone
who is just tall and just grabs them and
gets his arms around the whole thing and
you really have to try to do it uh just
having your arms on the sides yeah so so
um
being being uh as short as I am uh it's
uh in in some some part of the uh of the
things that we have to do is uh it's an
advantage and in others it's just well
that's why there's so many different
events right in the balance who's gonna
come out on top after all said and done
because no one's going to be the best at
every single one of them yeah that
that's the thing and that's what
separates it from for example
weightlifting because uh some people say
Okay weight lifter is is a strong guy
but actually a weight lifter is a
specialist for what they have to do
right they are really good at doing what
they do yeah and the guy in the
decathlon the guy who who who is the
best at the shot putter the hammer throw
isn't going to win the mile yeah that's
it
um and and the the purpose uh at
strongman is to have a perfect overall
test of all types of strength so at the
end of the day you get a winner who is
really overall a really really strong
guy that's that's what we try to
establish
um yeah so so
um
at least in the in the first year what
what I was able to do was I broke the
German uh the German record in my uh
weight category at the log lift so I
already that's got to be competitive
there's got to be a lot of strong German
guys that like to lift logs uh yeah
right
I mean overall uh in in strongman you
you have it's it's funny because um it's
it's almost like you have uh certain
eras where uh certain parts of the world
are quite dominant that's strong man it
begins uh in in the first years with
with the Americans because the whole
show started there yeah it started in
America so quickly I would imagine
Eastern Europe starts to there's
something between Eastern Europe comes
in the 90s but between that and the 80s
uh the northern countries um uh like uh
Norway
um and uh uh also Finland and and all
the Scandinavians Canton countries they
would and especially Iceland so up to
date uh Iceland had the most winners uh
uh overall in uh Edwards what do you
think that is
um if you look at the statistics you see
that the Icelandic people are uh the
tallest and the heaviest people on earth
and I think that helps
a little bit that's it okay and also
explanation solved right I mean they're
really strong and big there yet also and
there's nothing to do when it's dark out
all the time oh actually they're really
cultivated people uh I'd love to go to
Reykjavik I've never done uh I'm really
fascinated by Iceland never been there
but I really want to go there someday me
too
um so Iceland is really cool and um one
thing um that also plays a role I think
is is this Viking culture so so it's
this I mean if you have a culture where
it is cool to be strong and if as a
liking I think it it is cool to be a
strong guy
um that that helps of course and in
Germany you don't have that in Germany
Germans perceive themselves more as
intellectuals and and
um that sometimes really uh a problem
because um as a strength athlete some
sometimes you're just just a freak so um
and if you experience that that it
really doesn't help you in society to be
strong it probably uh prevents a lot of
people to trying to go for competitions
yeah that makes sense I mean I yeah I
get that yeah interesting um and also
what what plays a role is uh that that
you have some sports that build the
basis for uh what what you then build
upon to to get to the point uh to be
competitive as a strong man like in in
America you have that with with football
so most of the football players have a
quite good base uh that they can build
upon to to get into strongman
um and in the Eastern European countries
you would have all those weight lifters
and and wrestlers they have the perfect
base to um to build upon
the the Icelandic and the northern
people there like like I said they're
just big and strong that's it but then
like I said in the 90s you get to the
Eastern European guys they were quite
dominant in the 90s and also up to date
uh they are still quite dominant but in
the last I would say 10 years
um England and uh and the United States
are back in the game so you have guys
like Brian Shaw who uh one won the title
The the world's uh I think three times
now and uh Derek Poundstone who was more
type of uh guy
um comparable to me not not so tall but
but really uh built very very steady and
and a great over half overhead guy too
so um
yeah so
[Music]
um
it seems to to to have a certain certain
eras where uh right right the dominant
guys come from so so you're introduced
to this you do a couple of these
newcomer competitions and you kind of
work your way up as you kind of develop
this skill set and and where does it
click in like hey you're going to be
kind of like a top guy in the second
year in the second year
um I won uh my weight category for the
first time
um in Germany in Germany so uh it was
um 2007. so
um and then in
2009 I wanted again in 2008 I had a bad
year
um and now the important part of it is
that when you're a competing uh on
National level uh in Germany it means
that you're competing at the same
competition
um with the big guys so it's not that
there's no Nationals for uh the
lightweight guys and the special
Nationals for the big guys so the weight
classification doesn't come in until you
go to the international competitions
um yeah that's uh that's one thing and
uh another thing is
you have it you you get a title for your
division but you'll still have to do the
same thing that the heavyweight guys do
and then after the competition you have
like two different uh ranking systems so
you get ranked in your body weight
category and you also get ranked in the
overall category I see so you have like
two uh chances of winning the title if
if you're a freak of nature you could
win both titles I see so so are you
saying that in that that when you it was
a 2009 you win the German national
championships but you're actually
beating guys that are much bigger than
you you know yeah that's that's why
ordinarily would not be in your weight
class that's what I would try to get to
so what happened was in in both years
that I won my category
I was fifth in the overall so it meant
that only four guys were were able four
of the big guys were able to beat me
um and in 2010 uh or in 2009 it made me
think of
if I wouldn't have to stick to the body
weight
I thought probably I would be able to
beat those four guys too if I could put
on another 10 kilos or so of body weight
and try to be stronger than I was at
that point because at that point it was
already on a point where I really have
to force my body weight to uh um to not
to not get any heavier so I thought okay
if I unleash the these extra kilos
probably will help to to beat those guys
too
um which I didn't uh had I didn't
consider
um myself of as as being able to win
German Nationals um in the in the
heavyweight category before that but
then I thought okay I will give it a try
in next year right so screw the weight
classification I'm just gonna go for it
it doesn't matter how big these guys are
I'm gonna beat them at their own game
yeah I will just just try so I wasn't so
hard to go I wasn't so self-confident
but I thought okay I I'll try it this is
2010 yeah this 2010 right
um and you're still are you still
vegetarian at this point yeah
um I I hadn't gone vegan yet no I
haven't gone gone vegan but I'm a
vegetarian
for five years at that point and uh what
um so what what happens next is um
I will go back for for bodybuilding in
2000 after 2009 and in in that uh time
time span that that I prepared for
another bodybuilding competition that
the whole thing was about uh
I just wanted to find out if I would be
able uh after being a strong man and
being quite out of shape for a
bodybuilder I was just uh curious if I
would be able to get back into shape
um so I I thought okay
um I competed summer for uh for
strongman and I could uh compete in
Winter for bodybuilding and then after
the winter I could just get back to
strong man yeah so that was the plan
um
and um
at that time I I had a problem with with
concentrating
and uh I had for for quite a long time I
had some health issues too uh and one of
them being uh that I had a um
um
[Music]
constant low uh blood level of of iron
and I couldn't figure out what the
problem was so I would get supplements
iron supplements and it wouldn't help
anything
after I went vegan I found out that it
was all the dairy products because it's
dairy products they block your iron
intake and that was also the reason that
the supplements didn't help because it
doesn't matter so much how how much iron
you take as long as you have substances
that block the iron intake that you
can't absorb it they're not bioavailable
to you yeah what is it about the dairy
that blocks the iron absorption
um I don't know what what it exactly is
but there's several types of of foods
that do that one of them being Dairy
another is black tea yeah the cat the
tannins in in coffee and tea can can do
that as well
and what it is exactly in dairy products
I don't know but but it's one of the one
of the foods that uh that does that
um but I didn't know at that point and
uh the problem was um that that I had
all these issues and I tried a lot of
supplements and everything and didn't
help anything so you can't be a strong
man if you're anemic that's a problem
um you must have had doctors saying you
got to start eating meat again that
wasn't so much the problem because my
performances were quite good and then
also
um I wasn't really anemic but I was
always on the on the bottom level of of
of okay so it uh it was not that I
really felt bad or anything I was still
able to to compete and everything but um
what worried me the most was this uh
problems of concentrating
um and I didn't know if there was any
connection between the whole thing so um
at that point I I came to a point where
um my mom actually
um
um convinced me that not eating meat was
the problem
and at that point
um I thought okay I've tried all
different things
none of them seems to help so I'm going
to try to uh get back to eating meat for
for a certain
um
time period and see what happens it was
like 10 months or so where where I
started to to eat meat again it really
felt
totally
um
um
awkward because if you're like for five
years if you're away from that really
felt unnatural to me
um and that's why I gave it up after
after 10 months
um the also the iron deficiency uh
didn't uh didn't it didn't help anything
with the iron deficiency interesting so
you started eating meat again but it
didn't solve the low iron problem no it
didn't solve anything actually so after
10 10 months I I gave it up
um and um
and that was pretty much the time uh
period where I also
um uh prepared for the for the
bodybuilding show so after the
bodybuilding show uh
um I gave up bodybuilding for the rest
of my life because also my now uh wife
she told me if I would do that uh
anytime again she would just leave me
because why because it's such an insane
lifestyle or yeah the thing is we we
came together when I was already in the
preparation so but I was in the
beginning of the preparation so so what
what she when we um
when we got together she just
met this guy who was in quite good shape
and is quite charming and quite a nice
guy
and then within the next months I turned
into this hungry starving monster who is
in a ridiculous shape and who who has to
do six hours of cardio every day and
then after the the last hours of cardio
I would come come home and I would be so
um
um so exhausted and and so done that I
would just get rid of all these um
um soaking wet clothes and then
completely naked I would just fall into
uh into my bed and I would just
instantly uh um
um
fall into sleep because I was completely
out of energy right uh and for her it
was just shocking seeing seeing I was
how I was destroying my body on on that
level so uh she she told me okay there's
like no more of that if you do that
again I'm gone
um yeah and I'll stick to that so
um so I never done any bodybuilding
after that
um and also after the body building
competition I also was at the point that
I said okay this meeting each doesn't
make it it doesn't feel like that that's
not me that's that's so so I gave that
up to
um and I got back to to the vegetarian
diet
um and that was in 2009 and then 2010
was the first year where uh where I uh
got into the heavyweights
um and at that point uh going back to
the uh to the vegetarian uh uh eating it
also helped gaining weight again so I
gained at about
I mean I was competing on one 105
um in uh in 2009 but yeah kilograms but
my actual body weight would be probably
110 or so so I would uh have to cut five
kilos right but not like giant cuts no
uh but then in 2010 I gained it about
five kilos so my actual body weight was
115. so uh actually I was 10 kilos
heavier than than in the last
competition
um
and it worked out quite well so in in
the first year uh in the heavyweights I
uh became runner-up Champion uh at the
national for all of Germany yeah for uh
for Germany and uh 2011 was
um was my second try
um and then I won in 2011 I won the
heavyweights
um and what then happened was had a lot
to do with uh that I decided after uh
the competition to go vegan and it All
Began by a blog post that I made in my
in my web blog uh where I just wrote
that I had won this title and it's the
most prestigious title in in strength
Sports uh on a national level so I just
um yeah just bragged with uh be being
able to to get to that point
um and um just enjoyed the um the
experience and then the last sentence
that I wrote had a tremendous impact on
my life and the sentence was so I have
finally proved that it makes you a
better athlete being vegetarian
um and I think thousands of of
vegetarian people all around the world
they um they quoted that so you had to
quote all over the place in the web uh
in in in within like one or two weeks it
pretty much went viral and then the
media got uh got me on the radar so um
suddenly I had like big newspapers
calling me in Germany big TV shows and I
was guessed in all those shows and then
talks and everything and at that point
I um
I became aware of the fact that I was
through the media able to reach a lot of
people and really make a change like I I
had feedback from from people telling me
you have changed my life because after
seeing you on TV I thought about all
these things and what I was basically
saying in all those shows was that after
going vegetarian and after giving up
meat
my experience was that I even got
stronger and it even helped me with
performing so um all these people that
were afraid of uh that that felt like
okay I'm feeling
um uh compassionate with animals but I
think I'm going to lose my manliness or
or anything they they had this um
um I was able to
um to take away that uh uh um that worry
from them right of of losing anything
when when they uh get rid of meat so um
so I was getting all these feedback and
at that point I already knew that
being vegetarian for for ethical reasons
and and out of compassion it really
isn't enough because if you take a look
on uh the dairy industry and if you took
a look take a look on um how eggs are
produced and everything it's such a lot
of disgusting stuff that happens there
that you really if you come from a
compassionate point of view you really
want to uh not support any of these
things too so the actual answer would be
to go vegan but
um my problem was that it was not so
much about the X because I already was
not consuming I didn't consume a lot of
eggs at that point but I was consuming
massive amounts of dairy and in my
worldview at that point the dairy
products were my secret so so I thought
okay that's the reason I'm so strong
right and I thought okay if I get rid of
the dairy this is not going to work in
in any way I'm not going to be able to
maintain what I do now yeah so that's a
that's a moment of consternation like
that's a you're Suddenly at a at a sort
of fork in the road right because you
found yourself to be almost you know in
certain respects kind of an overnight
celebrity where suddenly you have this
platform and people are looking to you
as kind of an ambassador of of you know
this this movement and what it means to
be you know an ethical vegetarian and
yet here you are you know thinking oh
God drink all this you know like
realizing you know the sort of truth
behind the dairy industry three and and
reconciling that against this idea that
that's what's fueling your athletic
prowess yeah
so so it was really a problem and what I
thought was okay I would love to be um
to be a rep to represent veganism
uh and
for doing that I would have to go vegan
and then at the same time I thought okay
but but what is going to happen and if I
go vegan now and I'm now on a very high
level of of uh where you can get
competing
um and if I fail after going vegan
it's not going to help anything right
that's not going to help the movement
yeah and that was potentially hurt it
could potentially hurt the movement
absolutely it would even con it raises
the stakes for everything that for that
choice that you're going to make yeah
um so I was really worried about uh
different things
um and I thought okay if I want to do
that I will first have to do a lot of
research and find out how to do it right
at that point I I didn't even knew um
where to get any protein from that so I
didn't know anything because all the
years before protein was wasn't a a big
matter I was just drinking all these
milk and and having like three uh like
six pounds of of curd cheese a day right
so uh whey protein powder a lot of that
yeah a lot of all those this is still
we're talking about this is 2010 right
okay
so
um I mean at that point we were 2011
because I have won the title I just won
the title so um
so I'm thinking uh what what will I do
next
um and I'm starting researching uh what
a vegan diet looks like and if it's
doable and if I can get to do this and
then at a certain point I um just make
the decision to do it because I think um
okay um
I know that there is a way and I know
that I have done all those like I've
been able to take all these challenges
in uh in the last years and then in all
of my life so I'm going to find a way to
do it so I make the decision
um and the first person that I tell uh
that the decision I made is my mom
before your wife before my wife my now
wife at that point she's just my
girlfriend so so I um tell my mom and
she goes completely nuts she she
completely gets out of her mind and uh
she's like okay I I was I was okay with
all these stupid uh vegetarian thing but
now you're getting completely
okay completely out of control because
it just sounded so extreme to her to not
drink any milk to to not having any uh
Animal product
um and I thought okay I'm going to try
this with uh with my girlfriend
it might work uh work out better than
this so
so I told uh Katie
what I was planning to do and
um yeah so uh the same thing happened
she she goes completely nuts and the
same thing is when you when she didn't
want you to be a bodybuilder no the same
thing that happened with my with your
mom I got you okay so which is sort of
like the other things yeah okay so so
what happened was uh she she actually uh
um she actually said uh she she would
even uh break the relationship because
she said okay most of the time I'm
cooking so I don't actually want to cook
these strange plant stuff that you want
to eat so so that was one thing and then
she was uh like this is so extreme what
is going to be the next step so she was
afraid of me uh going into a development
where I would uh become an extremist and
she literally she literally uh said what
is the next step are you going to blow
up a butcher or uh or wow that's a leap
right yeah right that's an interesting
uh like mental bridge to build when
you're coming from a place of compassion
and she's going and and she's equating
that with a violent extremism and the
reason is that she's an omnivore at that
moment so so and and she's only with me
for for a year or so and also when she
got to knew me uh it was right in this
uh in this 10 months where where I was
eating meat so uh she we we got together
when she perceived me as a normal normal
person right and then uh I tell her okay
I've been vegetarian for a long time
before and I'm going to go back to that
and she's okay
you have done that so so she's vegan's a
whole different thing yeah but vegan is
not not good but yeah I mean it's
interesting that that's perceived as
being so extreme because you know in
sort of where I live it's sort of like a
it's kind of like the thing to do now
you know what I mean like uh is that but
that's not necessarily a German thing
that's more like a mom thing yeah yeah I
think it has a lot to do with um
um also with with the time it takes
place because a lot has changed since
then I mean one part of it is I have
been in such a lot of TV shows that I'm
like one part of this process that that
happens in Germany at the moment where
veganism is growing like mad and my mom
or or
um Katie uh if if the same thing would
happen now so if I wouldn't have made
the decision uh four years ago and I
would make it uh today the thing would
be completely different and also both of
them are vegan for more than two years
now oh your mom is too yeah yeah they're
both vegan now
um and um so but even if all of that
would take place now I think the whole
thing would be very different because
such a lot of things had have happened
uh in in the last four years
um and in Germany a lot of development
went on all right so
so you so you're vegan and you're like
you know whatever happens in the weight
room and the strength stuff is gonna
happen but this is what I'm doing so
then what then what's what's the next
thing yeah uh it's it's about that I
said okay I'm I'm going to make this
work I I'm going to find a way to make
this work
um and what that happens is that I get
completely shocked by the results
because
um and and what what I find out is that
I've completely lost these six years of
being vegetarian because all these
problems that I had like the iron
deficiency the heartburn that I had
throughout my life I found out that all
these problems come from the dairy from
the massive amounts of dairy that I um
would uh that I would consume and one of
my concerns was also that
um I mean there would be two ways to
fail the one way would be to do it to go
vegan and then fail at the competition
and the second way would be to try to do
it and then fail because I was so
addicted to uh to dairy products so
there was these two different ways to
fail you would lapse and go back to
eating dairy yeah yeah so and and what
what then happens is after three weeks
or so I just realized I don't have any
craving for dairy anymore
and there was another two months or so
uh but what was it what was that first
two weeks like
like did you have like not so bad too it
was really strange yeah it was strange
and awkward and and I even had the
feeling of uh getting weaker but the
good part of it was something that you
said uh earlier
um because I was uh training I was able
to to monitor my my numbers and they
were okay still I in my head I felt like
I'm getting weaker because it was so
awkward and it was so strange to to eat
in a very different way so I really
thought that I was getting weaker but I
wasn't and my numbers were great they
they just uh stayed stable what are you
replacing that there those dairy
products with yeah that's the best part
of it so in the last weeks before I made
the cut I would have massive amounts of
whey protein
um and this whey protein was uh I I got
it as a as a present uh from from my
friend that and that's the same guy that
I started training with uh back oh the
kid when you were 14 yeah back when we
were kids so he had made a big amounts
of whey protein that he was uh that he
was selling and he he stopped selling uh
the product at a certain point and he
just gave all everything that was left
he just gave it to me
um and you had like crates full of whey
protein yeah and that was the problem so
I was like okay if I throw Unlimited
Supply you're just during shake after
shake after [ __ ] no it was not that much
but but it was a lot so I also gave away
a lot of it but it wasn't uh it wasn't I
wasn't able to to sell it or anything
because it was already uh over the um
what is called um
the shelf life or whatever the
expiration date yeah so um I just
consumed it by myself and I thought okay
I'm going to consume that until it's
finished and then that's the point so in
uh in in in the months before uh the cut
I was pretty much 90 of my protein came
from this uh whey protein and then after
the cut I would just replace the whole
whey protein one by one by soy protein
which is actually not not a very smart
thing to do yeah but it was in a way it
was cool because
um I I could compare those two sources
one-on-one uh together and all the
effects that I had
um I can now really
um um
um count on on on this comparison
between soy protein and whey protein and
how did that balance out like what what
were the differences and that's the cool
part of it because you would normally
think okay whey protein is uh as an
animal protein you have the sulfur
containing amino acids you have all
these uh things that that over acidize
your body
um and with soy protein you would
probably think okay it's still not a
very good source of protein so um and
and that that's the good part of it
because
um my experience with my experiences
were so positive
that and and having a not perfect plant
Source even makes it better because if I
would have had the perfect plant-based
um right if you had a blend of of like
sprouted pea protein and hemp protein
and brown rice protein instead of soy it
would have been even that much better
but your experience was that just
replacing soy for whey actually was
better in what way like in you know what
aspect of it was it better so what
happened was uh I had for instance uh
heartburn throughout my life and uh I
always considered uh Dairy and and milk
as the remedy for that so when I uh had
heartburners I must have been the cause
yeah but I didn't do that and the
problem was that I have been addicted to
to dairy products for throughout my life
even as a child so I haven't had any
single day in my life where I didn't
drink any milk anyway where my body had
a chance to find out what is it what is
it like to not have any input any dairy
input and I also thought okay if if I'm
going to go vegan I'm going to die from
heartburn because I'm using all this
milk and and dairy products to uh to
getting rid of that and I don't want to
take any pills for that so let's see
what happens then and what happened was
after one or two days it just went away
and I was really shocked by that and I
didn't know what happened until I found
out about uh
the software containing amino acids and
I just realized that the dairy products
were actually the problem so it was like
trying to put a fire out by taking
massive amounts of wood and putting it
into the fire so in the first second I
mean if you drink a glass of milk of
dairy milk you you really feel better
and that's because uh I think one part
is because of the calcium it helps
neutralizing uh the
um the acid in your stomach and another
thing is you you just throw in uh
um
protein so the acid has something to do
and and it helps
neutralizing it but what actually
happens is you really throw uh wood into
into the fire so it goes on and that's
what I have been done uh throughout my
life and at that point I realized great
the fire just went away right and uh the
remedy was actually the Cause right yeah
that's so that's so interesting so so
from there I would imagine you begin to
that must have sort of encouraged you
and given you a certain level of
enthusiasm to say all right well let me
look into this more deeply and really
try to get it right like how can I dial
this up now that it seems the early
indications are that this is going in a
good direction for me yeah absolutely so
um what happens next is um
so so I have all these different
concerns that I had one was dying of
heartburn then all right so we checked
that box like that's no longer a worry
that was that was okay so so the next
one was failing because of the addiction
uh what happens is three weeks uh after
going vegan the addiction went away the
Cravings the Cravings are gone yeah the
microbiome changes yeah and no what I
find out is um I I find this uh radio
show
um on uh on on the web where uh
nutritionist just explains the the
biochemical basis for the addiction and
the the reason I use the word Addiction
is it is really an addiction oh no
question about it yeah because um it's
when you digest
um uh dairy products you have the dairy
protein which is made of whey protein
and casein and when you digest casein
you get this thing called casomorphines
and the chasomorphines are you already
hear it uh in the sound
or something like end or fine but but
they're called exorphines because they
do the same thing but they can't come
from the outside
and what in in nature the the role of
the whole thing is to make the baby cow
um the the cow uh to to feel better when
when it goes and drinks from uh from its
mom's breast
um and it makes totally sense because if
it gets a little bit addicted to doing
to to
um performing that Behavior Uh it is
going to get fed well right sort of
activating the pleasure Center in the
baby calf's brain yeah in the same
respect doing that to us as humans yeah
I've never heard that explanation before
that's interesting yeah me too uh right
after uh going vegan uh for two months
or so I I learned that and that was the
basis of the whole uh thing and the good
thing is it is really an addiction
that's why I'm using the word
um and the good thing about addictions
is once you get away from the drug for a
certain period
you're done the craving goes away at a
certain point and the only thing you
have to make sure is not to activate it
yeah not to reactivate it and then
you're good so after three weeks
I was cured so this one check that box
yeah check that box the third one was am
I going to be able to uh
stick to to the performance level and
I'm going to be able to uh to really
perform well
it was
um now we have to get back to this
heartburn thing so what actually happens
is
uh I'm not only getting uh getting rid
of the heartburn but I'm getting rid of
the over acidizing of my body and you
know what happens if you're not aware
acidized anymore right so so all these
dairy products are by their very nature
very acidic right and your body has to
work very hard to maintain essentially a
neutral slightly alkaline pH in your
blood system and when you sort of
bombard your system with with either
alkaline or acid you have to buffer that
your your system has to buff red so all
that dairy products your your system has
to buffer it by leaching alkalines out
of your bones which means taking calcium
out of your bones ironically which is
why you know sort of excessive Dairy
ingestion can lead to osteoporosis
against what most people believe but in
turn this leads to this state of like
chronic acidosis which causes
inflammation which leads to all these
you know chronic illnesses that so many
people suffer from yeah and one thing
you you mentioned is inflammation and
that's something that is quite crucial
when when you're doing a sport like uh
the the sport I do because it doing all
these movements uh with heavy weights
puts a lot of stress on your bones and
joints and it causes inflammatory uh
processes
um and so what you have is then a
situation where you are in constant pain
um being being uh being in in
competitions and in training
um and I realized that this level of
pain went much much better after several
weeks of uh being on a vegan diet
so that made me uh think about and and
then I um try to find out what was the
biological basis for that and I found
out okay if you're over acidizing your
body inflammation gets gets worse so um
it's it's just when you get rid of the
asset it also helps with that
um and that brought brought me to
another idea because
now we're six months after my mom uh
went nuts after I told her what I want
to do
um and my mom is suffering from um
um rheumatoid uh I tried this and that's
all about inflammation right and I
thought
this might be a good thing for her
um to help her with the inflammation and
she's she's in a state where she has to
constantly take painkillers and
um it's debilitating yeah really bad
yeah yeah and also uh she has to take
something against or try this itself
um and then I come with this idea and
and I tell her and I'm just like okay
you might think that's crazy but what if
you just try it for several weeks and
see what happens and she's like okay why
not if if it if it's able to help why
not and then she all she also has seen
me doing it for several months now so so
she knows okay
freaking out as much yeah he didn't die
yet and he looks good so he seems to he
seems to be uh do quitty uh pretty good
so uh she said okay she's going to try
it
um and that's it she tries it for
several weeks she gets rid of all the
painkillers her um her situation gets
much much better uh she reduces all uh
the things that that she had to take
against her try this to a minimal level
um and and she she is enlightened by the
whole thing that's amazing and and she's
vegan since that that's crazy yeah from
the freak out to being like an
evangelist that's yeah that's
extraordinary yeah so um so it worked uh
quite well with her and also um Katie um
got on the train uh just by realizing
what I was doing and also I mean I think
one crucial part was that I didn't try
to push anything on on both of the uh of
them I really didn't push them to to
anything I just um uh gave them time to
find it out for themselves I was just
teasing from time to time with some
jokes or anything but not nothing more
um and I think with Katie it helped a
lot that she was always with me when I
would give all these interviews and and
for TV shows or stuff like that just
wore her down like she kept hearing the
same thing over and over again yeah it
starts to plant the seed yeah that's
that's the thing and it really helped
that um I I used all these um uh all
these arguments but not directed towards
not not to her Direction but in another
Direction and she was like
um
um just a Beholder and and she just
listened to it and and something
happened in in her ad interesting cool
so we still we still have this one box
yet that I'm not sure that we've checked
which is your ability to perform
athletically like everything sort of
seems like it's coming together in the
gym and suddenly you're experiencing
much less inflammation which you know
what that translates into is improved
recovery time like if you don't have as
much inflammation you're able to train
harder and bounce back more quickly
which is going to allow you to really
kind of hit it harder and faster and
more frequently and I would imagine you
know at least my experience was that
that translates into you know pretty
significant performance gains in a
shorter period of time that's it that's
exactly what happens so one part of it
is that I get rid of inflammation so I'm
able to train harder I'm able to uh
recover FAFSA and and train more that's
the one thing and then the other thing
is the body have has all these
regulatory
um
processes where uh if you give too much
of anything it blocks it or it doesn't
take it in anymore and when right like
if you start taking uh exogenous
testosterone you know your body's going
to shut down its own uh endogenous
production of tests yes right and you're
going to get rid of your testicles yes
that's that's what happens yeah so um so
the body has a way of balancing
everything out if it gets too much of
anything and what happens if you give
the body protein that over acidizes the
body is the body just stops taking in
protein and that's something you're not
absorbing that protein yeah and that's
something that a lot of bodybuilders do
without knowing it and that's something
that I realized after going vegan so
what happened was
I just realized I didn't even have to
have the same amount of protein to get
the same results and
um
so
it's really funny because a lot of
people think if you go vegan you have to
eat more what actually happened was I'm
eating less now and I'm even
taking less protein and I'm 10 kilos
heavier than I was before so I'm 130
kilos now and your explanation would be
that your body is able to absorb these
nutrients and and perhaps maybe the
nutritional density of the foods that
you're eating is is is greater or no the
nutritional date and density is quite
the same but what what really happens is
that my um
my metabolism is much more efficient
than it was before right and that's
because it's not over acidized if you're
over acidized your metabolism is
completely inefficient so you have to
just just have much more input for the
same result that I have now
right so that's super interesting wow
all right so so do you have so when's
the next competition where you kind of
put this to the test yeah so the next
competition is uh the European
championships in in powerlifting where I
uh compete uh suddenly you're in an
all-new sport yeah but but
powerlifting not really uh what I have
left out right when I when we were
talking about the first years was that I
I done a lot of powerlifting uh
competitions too so that's something
that I had done uh in in the years
before and that's actually the thing
that I'm really built for so I'm doing
strong man because because it's much
more fun and powerlifting is only these
three movements and right you're like
killing it in the in the sort of power
lifting uh aspects of the strong man but
it's the power lifting where you really
can shine yeah because I'm short and uh
especially for for the bench present for
for the uh for the squad it really helps
when when you have short limbs so that's
something that I'm actually built for
um what about when the the knife blades
come out of your knuckles what do you
yeah for that's that's really a problem
when deadlifting
because sometimes there's some holes in
the ground right yeah
touch yourself too
um anyway go ahead no so um that that's
actually the the first competition that
I do as a vegan it's um I think
let me think uh I think it's four or
five months after going vegan
um and it's in Finland and I uh win my
category and I win the the overall
championships even with all those big
strong finish guys yeah
[Laughter]
so um yeah so um that's that's the first
uh the the first competition where I
have can put it to the test and in terms
of like your number I mean what were you
you know in terms of like the actual
amount of weight like were you hitting
your PR's or where were you you know no
in in that regard uh
um the powerlifting thing is uh not very
useful because
um before going to the powerlifting
competition I I didn't uh train for that
so I started training for that like six
or eight weeks uh before going to the
competition so it's there's no uh way to
um to compare anything I see but where
we uh can compare is um if you like take
a look at I mean I I think the the the
log or or the yoke is probably the best
uh way to look for for having a um a
comparison because I have done uh um
heavy yoke walks
throughout the the whole time like even
one and a half years before uh before I
went vegan so um
I already started to to do heavy yolk
walks and I was able to
handle or or did this 10 meter thing I
was able to do with 460 kilos
and then after going vegan and uh being
vegan for for two years
um I did the world record with 500. yeah
that's the one where I was there yeah
550. and you just recently set another
world record yeah yeah it was is the
same thing but five kilos more ah okay
um and I was awesome you did that here
in Germany uh yeah at uh at the last
competition and so how fast did you do
that one uh it was 28 seconds and 28
seconds faster or 28 seconds total 28
seconds total and did you have to did
you set it down like you did yeah yeah I
just said it I set it down once but uh
yeah but but this time it was almost uh
almost
um the the 10 meters were almost done
and I had to set it uh set it up once
but just because I tried to be a little
bit faster and then it didn't work in
the interim in between when I saw you in
Toronto and this most recent world
record
um has anybody tried to challenge it
like have other people attempted to to
do the Yoke with more weight and failed
or are you out there like you know in
The Fringe like doing this on your own a
day um they have tried or or they have
challenged it but the problem is that
they went for a completely different
distance so they
um this uh there's been one competition
where uh the the Arnold Classic actually
where they went for three meters
um and obviously if you go for three
meters compared to 10 meters there's
something completely different so how
much did that how much did that do they
yoke for three meters Dave went for 600
and
what was it 600 and
uh
680 kilos or so that was the heaviest uh
they they went they did that for for uh
two consecutive years and I really
thought it was a Pity that they uh went
for for only three meters because it
would really have been cool too uh have
a direct comparison right because three
meters is we're talking about like three
or four steps versus what like 15 12 I
mean how many steps do you take when
you're doing this I mean meters I mean
my distance was uh
uh 30 feet compared to 10 feet right so
it's it's really something uh different
and I also I mean one of the problems is
that you um you're the you're the
endurance athlete of yoke lifting of the
yolk yeah after the Yoke walk Iron Man
Ultra yoga
yeah not really because 10 meters is
also quite a short distance
but but three meters it's like an
eternity when you have that much weight
on you right so it is the ultra
endurance distance of yoke walking
yeah awesome all right so you know the
idea behind this is I mean it almost
seems like and tell me if this is fair
like this is a way to sort of Advance
your your your kind of advocacy you're
in this position right where you have a
microphone all of a sudden and you have
all these people paying attention and
listening to you and you could continue
to do you know sort of power lifting of
you know competitions and strong man Etc
but by saying I'm going to try for this
world record and just sort of self-style
this adventure and create attention
around that is a way to kind of
um put a microscope on uh not only your
athletic prowess but also uh you know
the issues that that you care about yeah
absolutely so um
the main reason that that I went vegan
was that I was trying to be a good um
good example and uh being someone who
influences a lot of people I thought I
really have to uh try to be the best
example that I can be and that was the
main motivation to to really do it and
that's really what I do in the last four
years that I really try to find ways um
of
um of really getting the message out to
people
um why why am I doing the whole thing uh
and and also get people's attention and
to get people to their attention I
really from time to time have to do
something crazy to get the media to get
yeah it's a funny thing because you have
to do something really really kind of
outrageous in order to get that kind of
attention and then people say yeah but
that's unhealthy and outrageous
[Laughter]
so it's a weird it's a weird thing like
that but um uh you know that I want to
ask you about let's see how long we've
been going here um I don't want to take
it whoa we've been going for a while uh
we've been going almost two and a half
hours dude uh all right we gotta go eat
soon but I can't let there's a couple
things that I I really want to talk to
you about before I can let you go and
the first thing is is you know sort of
given where you are now and that that
kind of you know responsibility that you
yoke just like you Yoke the weights you
know how do you uh how do you kind of um
uh
uh think about
how you Advocate you know what I mean
because I think that especially with
veganism and issues around food it can
become very emotional there's a lot of
passion you know and there's different
ways of carrying the message and and you
see like there's a lot of sort of uh
finger pointing and judgment and anger
uh you know that comes with people that
are passionate and see the world in a
particular way and you strike me as
somebody who you know is carrying a
message of compassion with a great deal
of compassion and and non-judgment yeah
and that's really what I uh try to do
what I try to do is um
um
uh when I talk to people I always take
my own perspective before I went vegan
and I try to talk from that perspective
um and I try to
um just make them understand certain
things by letting them
um by letting them
um
experience my own thought processes so
so I will tell them what what my
concerns were like like we did in the
last two hours I just told you what my
concerns were and then I tell them what
my experiences were when I really did it
and the good part of that is that I
don't have to judge people in in any way
because what I'm actually doing is I'm
just telling them my story and what
happened and then they have all this
information without having the feeling
that I try to push something on them and
I think that's a really crucial part of
the whole thing because as soon as
people feel pushed in in a certain
direction in most cases you will have
this um natural smack yeah it's like a
reflex they will find or try to find
ways
um to to judge you to to to to to to
because as soon as yourself image is is
threatened you find ways to to get rid
of that threat and one way is to just
not listen and that's what I don't want
so I really want them to to to listen to
me so I can get the information into
their brains and to make them listen I I
really try to be as um
unjudgmental as as I can be because I
know that that's that's poison if you if
you have the feeling that that some
somebody is judging you that's just
poisoning the whole um communication
right yeah it kind of brings up
something we were talking about on the
train earlier when you talk about like
sense of identity and trying to preserve
that sense of identity or or whatever
your world view might be right and we
were talking about how uh you know when
you're doing something that's sort of
unusual like that doesn't really compute
uh like oh how can you how can you carry
so much weight and and not eat animal
products like that that's bizarre
doesn't make sense to me oh well it must
be you know either like Patrick's lying
you know there's one eyes he's full of
it and when he's when no one's looking
he's eating meat he said that or you're
a freak of nature and you're an outlier
so you know that doesn't apply to me
which allows you to preserve your world
view because you're kind of threatening
you know a sort of a cultural Paradigm
and it's interesting how the human being
reacts to that to try to to uh you know
sort of uh make sure that that you know
the the way that they see the world is
not threatened by as a result of of your
actions right and that's a very natural
thing we always have to remember that
that's a absolutely natural thing
because the one thing that gives you
um that gives you some some sense of
um of certainty and some some say some
sense of um being safe in this world is
the feeling that you know how the world
works and as soon as someone tells you
something that is totally
contradicting something that you really
believe in deeply that shakes your whole
world and it's frightening yeah and it's
absolutely normal and and very natural
that people try to find ways to save
that
um that building that they have built in
inside their mind
um from from the earthquake that that
comes because
um going back to what we said before
these things that we are doing without
knowing why we are doing them there are
fundamental things things like
relationship if you tell someone that
they're in love with this one person
that they think that everything comes
totally naturally and this two people
relationship is completely natural and
it comes from themselves and you tell
them no that's just culture if you if
culture tells you something else you
will be married to five people or so
that shakes their whole world
and it's of course everyone is going to
say no that it's it's me and it's uh
it's it's like like I believe in
um and and and that's a problem that's
the reason why you really have to be
um
um
very careful in in the way you
communicate because uh
um because it's you always have to
remember the impact of of of the message
that you are carrying it's it's a huge
impact and
um
so it's like carrying a big explosive
weapon with you right and and not
knowing what what you're actually doing
and just detonating it all over the
place irresponsible and that's what
happens when you when you look at uh
discussions uh in in the internet when
when people get mad at each other
almost in a in a virtual way they almost
kill each other yeah yeah that's what
happens the the vegans really forget how
explosive this this message is that that
they are carrying and that's something
that we really have to remember every
day yeah and I think it brings up uh
issues of masculinity as well you know
and as you know we're both athletes
we're very different athletes it's one
thing for me you know some skinny long
distance Runner guy to talk about like
this lifestyle uh it's another thing
altogether for a guy of sort of you know
your strength and stature to to be
advocating it and and I think it's
impossible to have this conversation
without talking about
um you know what that means in terms of
of identity you know and so much of our
cultural Paradigm or our world view as
men you know is is premised on this idea
of the hunter-gatherer or the sort of
you know Alpha who who brings home the
bacon literally uh and to say that no
you know to decouple your identity from
that you know sort of uh activity is
also a very is very threatening to to
the world view
um and so how do you sort of speak to
that because you're you're really kind
of like you know you're the torch Bearer
I think when it comes to that
um what one thing that I do is I try to
uh make uh people
um understand where where this whole
idea of uh this connections uh this
connection of um manliness and meat
eating where it really comes from and uh
you you had it uh with the perfect uh
words it comes really from from this
archaic uh
um his historic times where um
like
Min would uh would compare against each
other uh to to find out who is the best
hunter so if you're the best hunter you
are going to bring the most meat home so
there's already this connection between
meat and being being a real man and
that's something that uh went uh it's
not it didn't translate into all
cultures uh one one to one but it's
subliminally it's it's uh within uh
within pretty much all cultures except
uh some some cultures in in India where
you have vegetarians
um it's it's pretty much there
everywhere
um and um
just by trying to um
making people aware where it comes from
I think that helps already a lot to
Breaking this uh this uh Association
that people have in their minds so
that's uh something that I try to do and
then another thing is of course
um something that is not uh I mean it's
not possible to put it into word but I
just try to um help with that issue by
doing what I do so I mean if you have
this guy
um who is
overweight who has a long beard who is
pretty much every uh has every aspect of
what you would consider uh to to be
manly and is able to uh like um just
walk through a closed door if he wants
and he's carrying like a horse on his
shoulders and so on so you have this
strange guy
um and he is able to do all of this and
he is able to be himself without having
to eat meat or without having to uh
consume any animal products
um there's actually no no questions left
yeah I mean it's it's your actions and
what you do as an athlete are going to
speak more loudly than anything that
comes out of your mouth and I think you
know that must inform your decision to
return to competition because I think
when I'd seen you last you were like
yeah I'm not going to compete anymore
like I just I don't feel like I want to
compete against other other other people
but you're like yeah I'm kind of getting
back into it I mean is that what's part
of that absolutely so so that there's
two reasons the one reason is uh after
retiring for two years
um I just um so what one thing that I've
seen is no one is doing my job so I was
I was expecting of someone uh getting
into uh into the game and and just doing
what I do now and that didn't happen for
two years the human Wolverine Junior to
step in your place
[Laughter]
so so that's that's the one thing and
then another thing is that um I just um
um I just have the feeling that um
I mean one of the reasons to um to go
away from competitions was that
um I thought I'm going to find more
effective ways to communicate the whole
thing without having to go on with
sports because after all I'm getting I'm
getting older and at a certain point I'm
not going to be able to improve and
that's the point where where I don't
know if uh I'm going to be any help for
for the movement also because if I don't
improve people are going to say ah look
now I have to go in vegan uh it's it's
done right which is the other thing we
were talking about earlier which is you
know this this art this other argument
that could be thrown at you like oh well
you got strong before you went vegan so
it doesn't really count yeah and that's
something that that is not uh not
accurate because
um I'm actually on on on on certain uh
um events I can show that I'm stronger
and I'm also heavier and much much more
muscle than I was before but I went
vegan so it's not that I maintain what I
had before but I build upon that and I'm
even better now
um I mean the perfect way to see that is
really just by looking at the yolk and
if you see that four years after after
going vegan I'm still able to to beat my
uh my own record and
and it even doesn't uh matter so much if
it wouldn't be a world record anymore
because the the really important thing
is I'm beating myself from from time
from time to time so I can really show
that I'm getting stronger and I think
that's the really important part of it
the world record thing is just important
to get the media attention and to get
people to talk about it
um so so
um
um
so so one thing was that that I thought
okay I think
um being able to travel the world and
and having all these talks and and uh
getting the information uh to people
through media and everything and also
writing books so that's what what I uh
actually did after afterward the world
record in in 2013 I I wrote a book wrote
my first book so I thought okay this is
going to be a more effective way of
getting the information out to people
um and in in my into intellectual uh
world view that that was how the world
works but um unfortunately that's not
really how the world works so people
really want to have these crazy things
and that's something that that I found
out and then I thought okay I'm now 36
and I probably have
two three or four more uh good years in
me so um
I really should uh I really should use
these uh years that I have in me and uh
try to do as much as I can to to really
get this thing going and that that's why
I'm back that's what you're talking
about yeah so so what's the next big
challenge uh next thing would be uh for
for next year to I mean one thing is I'm
going to go go on with the yolk and I'm
also going to go for the shorter
distance because
one thing that that I had when I set the
world record first was um I it was also
called the heaviest weight human being
has ever carried and I want to have that
back so I'm going to go for that you've
got to go the three meter and put on 685
or something right seven 700 let's see
what what what's going to work I already
went to 640 in training so um we'll see
right so that that's one thing then
another thing is I'm going to get back
to Nationals
um and uh one thing that I would really
like to do power lifting or strong doing
strong man so one thing that I really
want to do is I want to regain the title
because I never had it as a vegan so it
would be a really uh big argument if I
could show that I'm able to to regain
the title as a vegan and of course next
year will be my fifth Year's uh my fifth
years and what what month is that
um that that's throughout the year it's
it's a series of competitions oh I see I
see so isn't like one weekend where you
show up and do it no it's like points
accumulated over the course of that
period of time I got you cool all right
well we got to lock it down here but but
the last thing I want to know about
before we do that is walk me through a
day in the life of Patrick in food and
training because there's no way you can
we can close this podcast down without
me at least ask you what you eat and how
you train yeah we left it to the very
end but yeah still you know tell me a
little bit about that yeah so so a lot
of the categories that I uh take in are
in liquid form and it starts in the
morning when I get up um and that's
something that I have done before going
vegan uh so why is that
um
the thing is when I get up I'm I don't
have any appetite but I still want to
want to take in calories because that's
um the one thing is after sleeping for
eight hours I really want to give my
body some nutrients as fast as possible
and another thing is um
I need energy for the day so I need to
get some some calories in but um
usually in in the morning in the first
two hours I don't have any appetite
right so what I will do is I will have a
big shake or a big smoothie a shake
would probably be a baboon Shake which
is of course which is in your book yeah
you saw it so so it's a lot of oatmeal
um and then it's uh chocolate soy milk
and it's
um
it's also some chocolate flavored uh
vegan protein powder this is like the
weight gainer morning Shake yeah this is
that's it all right so not even one leaf
of kale in there uh
uh not necessarily
all right
so that that's the first thing that I
would have in the morning uh that's
that's pretty much my breakfast
um then two hours later
um I will just have normal lunch like
like anyone else and that could be
probably uh
a rice dish with tofu like uh tofu sweet
sour with sweet sour sauce and rice and
some some veggies that that's it some
Thai veggies or anything
um
then after that uh an hour later or so I
would uh have
for instance a big smoothie
and then two hours later I'm already
within the range of of my workout so I
will have my pre-workout Shake which is
just a shake on water basis with some
vegan protein powder so the first
training session of your day isn't until
the afternoon you don't you don't do any
training in the morning yeah that's
that's it
um
and usually I'm even training uh um even
later but uh it depends on what what the
rest of the day will look like
but we are not now pretending that it's
going to be an afternoon so I will have
my uh pre-workout check
then there's training and after training
I will have a big smoothie so you you
already see there's only one uh real uh
meal until that point and everything
else is like right right then after the
big smoothie uh there's going to be
another
um meal it's it's going to be Pro
probably the same thing that I had for
lunch
um for for a second time
uh then
um after that uh I will have probably
some snake some snacks I wanted to say
some snakes some snakes yeah what kind
of what what are the snacks
um sometimes peanuts a lot of times it's
it's just peanuts or some tortilla chips
or anything so um but but often it's
just peanuts or um just just some
um or just just some way nuts or
Wellness or anything
um and then uh in in the evening uh
before right before I get I get to bed I
will have uh another protein shake that
reason uh for the last uh protein shake
is just to get some protein in before I
get to sleep so I will so I have
something for for these eight hours of
sleep uh that that
um that stays in my body and um uh still
not uh not wanting to
um having my stomach full uh before I
before I go so how many grams of protein
a day are you taking in you think um
I try to get 300 grams but in most cases
uh it's it's three 250 or something so
it's between 250 and 300 grams and and
what does the training look like like
what's a typical day in training uh
training can be very very different
depending on what I'm preparing for
um the latest book is really about
functional strength training right like
which is being out in nature and
actually sort of you know yeah but but
it's not so much um so what I uh what I
try to cover in the book is not so much
my own training uh but um I try to put
put together a program that makes sense
and covers all the knowledge and uh that
I acquired uh in the in the last uh two
decades
um but it's for someone normal right so
it's nothing like what what I do every
day because I wouldn't consider it uh
any uh good idea for for someone who is
working in the office or someone who
just wants to get a little bit stronger
or anything to do what I do yeah so
because my training is very special very
specialized and is always very focused
on on the next uh competition and the
next challenge that that is in front of
me so if you're if you're looking at
like you know the the next yoke
challenge you're gonna you're gonna
you're looking at you know Crossing 10
meters with you know 560 plus kilograms
on your back so so you know just maybe
just give me you know what what one
workout would look like so training will
really replicate what I want to do in in
the competition so what I do at home is
I I pretty much simulate the the whole
thing
um
um and I I trained with the same
implements and um I have this like like
a prima pyramide uh uh style uh
um
a series of sets where I start with a
with quite a
lightweight and then I work my way up
right until I get reduced the number of
wraps as you increase the weight and
build up and build back down or
um as as I'm not doing sets with uh with
the Yoke
um I mean on on the first runs uh I will
probably do a longer distance I see
right but uh but as I you're not doing
any reps it it just stays how it is and
it gets just just gets heavier and so
you give the body the the chance to uh
accumulate to to the uh Progressive uh
do you have like a periodized training
schedule where you sort of ramp up the
intensity and then have rest days or
rest weeks and then build back up again
like what is the and you know and and
sort of piggybacking on that do you work
with a coach or do you have mentors that
give you feedback on your training and
where you're at
um uh I'm a trained coach myself
so I I know all the principles of uh
periodization and and everything and I
don't use it uh because
um
it's
um when when you're doing a strong man
um the variety of of things that you uh
that you have uh to do to uh to to
prepare for something is is such a big
variety that you don't actually need
paradization because you actually uh
because you're mixing it up so much yeah
because because you normally would do
that to uh not to avoid plateaus
um and there are no plateaus for me
because as soon as I uh um get to a
plateau with one thing I just start
training another thing and so I don't
really need that
um it will it would probably still make
sense because
um because you're also avoiding uh to
just overwhelm your body but the problem
with that is I have this strange mindset
I um I'm not able to perform on 80 when
I go into training so I'm just not able
to do it I I sometimes I'm tired and I
think okay today I'm going to have a
light day and I'm just going to go for
70 or so but as soon as I'm in training
I just can't stop I don't know do you
have the same thing yeah I know what
you're talking about it's not always so
good no no of course you can get into
trouble that's how you get injured and
that's how you over train yeah
absolutely I still really try to be
smart and uh when I and I have a quite a
good feeling uh to to where I know at at
which degree I can push my body and
where where the right point is to to
stop so um I'm quite lucky with injuries
um not being injured a lot in in all
those years that I train but
um but but as I said I'm just not not
really able to to stop myself
when it comes to you take it do you take
do you train seven days a week do you
have a rest day or I I have a lot of
rest days because the the problem with
uh with what I do is it puts such a lot
of stress to to the bones and and all
those structures that need a lot of time
to recover the tendons and so on uh and
the problem with that is your
performance is going to go up quite fast
but if you make use of of that and you
stick to training you get over trained
very very fast and the problem is that's
exactly where uh the injuries come
because your muscle is getting stronger
before your tendons can accumulate to
that
um and so so I have to take a lot of
days off so usually I will train one day
and then I will have two days off at
least so in a week I will have
at about three uh training days normally
I'm in the wrong sport
[Laughter]
but but most of the time when I'm taking
days off I'm in pain so I don't know how
it is for you all right man well clearly
we could wrap it out all day long but we
got to close it down we gotta go eat
everyone's waiting for us so uh that was
amazing thank you so much I think we did
it right did we do it I think so you
feel good it was it was we made it
through without you having to take a
break to have a protein smoothie either
right yeah I probably lost uh two pounds
or so all right man we'll go out there
and uh break another world record so you
can come back and and tell me all about
it will you will do all right man you're
an inspiration thanks so much I
appreciate it man I love you brother and
I can't wait to see what you do next
thanks Rich um so you just have the
brand new book out
I don't know what it's called in German
so tell everybody what the exact title
is yeah it's uh in uh I translated
I translated into into English it's
functional strength training uh for
Heroes is it in English language or only
German language uh at the moment it's in
uh German but today uh we we were at the
book fair and we talked to uh to an
English publisher so probably in the
next few months uh we'll get it out in
the states too oh that's cool all right
but if you speak German and you're
listening uh you should definitely check
it out you can get it at amazon.de right
yeah that's right there it's probably on
amazon.com I'm sure so that's exciting
man congrats on the new book are you
working on another book
um I'm just I just published this one I
have I already have uh the idea for
three other books in my head uh but I'm
yeah well when you're only training
three days a week you got no excuses to
current you can crank books out
I'm actually going to start writing uh
on the next one but it's going to be
something completely different all right
good well I look forward to it man and
uh what's the best place uh for people
to go online who want to learn more
about you and connect with you
um you can find me on Facebook and on
YouTube
um uh on Facebook just uh Patrick
uh and then on YouTube I'm the world's
strongest vegan
right so man and my home page is the
veganbadass.com yeah if you can and you
can get can can people buy those cool
t-shirts that you make yeah at
videobedass.com all right awesome man
thanks so much let's go eat yeah let's
go thank you peace
plants
[Music]